[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to day three of the coverage
here at midas media network
uh thanks for joining us it is day three
yesterday we know was postponed until
next week looks like we're gonna have
two hearings next week
at the same time they are moving these
hearings to the afternoon welcome
welcome welcome i am the tony michaels
with the tony michaels podcast hosting
your coverage today we're we are an hour
early to the gavel so that we can get
some commentary we have some great
guests but there's a lot of breaking
news this morning um as we go into
the hearings here um and i want to ask
our guests in our panel but before that
i want to talk about some of this news
there were some statements from the
witnesses
this morning that were released uh greg
jacobs who is the formal counsel to the
vice president mike pence released a
statement but one of the most damning
statements this morning was released by
the honorable j michael lutwig i think
is how we say it he's the retired judge
from the u.s court of appeals of the
fourth circuit um and he's an informal
advisor to mike pence on the situation
about january 6 of mike pence
certifying or not certifying the result
um that is huge news this morning the
other huge news this morning we we hear
the chairman of the january 6th select
committee benny thompson is going to be
considering calling clarence thomas the
supreme court justice's wife jeannie
thomas who we know was texting uh
cubanon conspiracy theories to mark
meadows uh trying to get the election
overturned but also
also in emails we see that she was
trying to overturn electors in other
states including arizona but the other
emails you know
we had we had uh
in 2016 there was this email lady that
ran for president oh her emails all her
emails lock her up lock her up that was
the that was the thing we heard over and
over and over and over again we still
hear it from fox news today
jenny thomas
um is the new email lady i guess where
she is emailing
john eastman which i believe that we're
supposed to see some clips today of john
eastman taking the fifth amendment i
know a lot of uh manga world out there
can't understand much much of the
amendments past the second amendment uh
they don't really understand the first
the second but the fifth amendment
uh is the right to not to
self-incriminate so i i believe we're
going to see john eastman uh on film
today do that i'm not sure how many
clips are going to pull up mr eastman
but in light of the email news from
jeannie thomas the wife of clarence
thomas the supreme court justice um i
believe we're going to see some of that
now
we also have news from jamie raskin um
this morning i on cnn i believe is where
the reporting is coming from jamie
raskin has said that we are going to
find out who the back channel to trump
was from the proud boys i don't know i
can't find clarification if that is
today
um but i i
i'm almost sure
i'm almost sure that
we will get that sometime in these
hearings now whether it's today next
week or some of these other hearings
that we are going to be broadcasting
here jamie raskin has told cnn that we
will find out who the back channel
to
donald trump was and that leads me to my
very very first guest
michael cohen uh michael cohen is in the
trump or he's uh he was uh
donald trump's personal attorney we know
that uh he actually went to federal
prison and served time for some of the
things
uh that that donald trump has done but i
want to ask him about this back channel
michael how are you this morning how are
you tony oh i'm doing great i'm doing
great so there's a lot of news here and
we're going into this hearing but
one thing i want to ask you is this back
channel and and the reason why is
because it seems like donald trump used
a lot of back channels right they used a
lot of back channels um and i just want
to ask why they would use back channels
and why this may be
big news that jamie raskin is saying
we're gonna find this out
so
give me an example what back channel
that you're looking into you know i you
know i hate this donald is an
interesting guy and i was very clear
when i stated before the house oversight
committee that trump
acts like a mob boss so nothing is done
right up into your face if people are
sitting and expecting
that there's going to be a video of
donald turning and saying yeah let them
storm the capital let them attack the
capitol police let them hang mike pence
you're going to be very disappointed but
what he does is he speaks in code so
tell me tony what is it that you're
specifically looking um
you know for me to answer why you know i
don't i don't know i don't know what
exactly this back channel could look
like i mean obviously we know uh from
court records that stu rhodes the oath
keepers and the proud boys were in some
sort of coordination on on january 5th
and then they had a qrf a stash of
weapons there's evidence to show in the
public court records that possibly they
had they were waiting for authority from
someone um stewart rhodes it
being reported by bob costa and seth
macfarlane or excuse me scott mcfarlane
that that uh stuart rhodes the founder
of the oath keepers was trying to make
contact with
donald trump that day so it would seem
that maybe there was a back channel
there
to do that communication i guess what
i'm asking is
is that typical of trump to have a back
channel to different information so he's
not tied directly to this stuff yeah so
he's not directly tied to whatever is
going on whatever
scheme or
crime possibly that may be committed
right
by the way tony too bad it's not seth
macfarlane because then this would be
actually funny if it wasn't if this
wasn't reality it would really be funny
i mean this is like a bad episode of
house of cards or something so you are a
hundred percent correct donald always
speaks in code donald always has a back
channel so i had spoken to jennifer
lawrence who i know that she and her um
fiance had both testified before this
committee and one of the things that
they had expressed to me is that there
were um there was a mom and a daughter
by the last name of kramer and they were
the ones that actually went out and
acquired these burner phones they bought
them at either a cvs or a walgreens or
something like that uh paid in cash of
course and then wanted the receipt that
for the individual that they sent to go
get it what's interesting is that the
allegations that i have heard is that
the communication was going on between
mark meadows and the cramers on the
outside while of course the insurrection
the attack on the capital was occurring
now again we get to the question was
donald trump involved clearly the answer
is no one's doing this on their own just
as i didn't pay stormy daniels the 130
000 right without donald trump knowing i
mean the notion that something like that
is even possible is just it's ludicrous
the same thing took place in washington
the same thing took place in the white
house nothing went on there without
donald trump being actively involved and
fully apprised because that's the way
that he ran um the government you know
the white house while he was president
it's the way he ran the trump
organization when he was the president
there
so what you're saying is is that you're
you're it's not surprising to you
that that he would have a back channel
if that if
to whatever whether it be the
insurrection whether it be the proud
boys rather be members of congress so
having these back channels would not be
something
um
different for donald trump is that which
i mean is that what you're kind of
saying is he
in a nutshell that's exactly right
there's always there's always an out for
donald right that's the that's the one
thing that he's exceptionally good at
and that's ensuring that his ass always
remains you know uh
and protected and everybody else
it's like a martin scorsese movie right
it's like a martin that i know
goodfellas you know no one ever talked
to this person it was always through
this person and through this person and
through this person so you can create
those levels of plausible deniability if
you want to take a look at sure take a
look at the movie american gangster
right with denzel washington nobody talk
to me everybody has to go through hughie
right right right
you go to huey huey comes to me that's
the same way with donald and look the
question is whether mark meadows will
actually get up and testify because mark
meadows is a significant part of this
thing it's not just him though it's his
son eric and his daughter-in-law lara
it's you know kimberly gargoyle and you
know and don jr uh it's rudy kaluti
drunken giuliani i mean something i've
talked about on television and i
remember everybody laughing they thought
it was funny when i said the most
dangerous place to ever be is in between
rudy and a bottle of chardonnay or a
free bottle of chardonnay or scotch
that's a dangerous place to be and
that's exactly that's what was going on
there these guys all thought that they
were going to be able to overturn the
election that they were going to be able
to impose their will over that of the
will of the voters the american people
and when they ultimately realized that
that's not gonna happen right and that
was whether it was eastman or whether it
or not it was um you know uh meadows or
whether you have don junior saying you
know this has to stop or ivanka pleading
with her father daddy daddy this has to
stop you know
it all comes back to donald right you
know there's the old expression the edge
you probably saw it once or twice on the
boss's desk right the buck stops here
well not with donald if that buck
doesn't end up in his pocket if that
could end you know if that buck could
end you up in prison rest assured it
will be everybody before him
hopefully he'll end up being held
accountable for his own you know
criminality uh and for his own illegal
actions
so i want to show you a little clip here
of the the statement from the judge this
morning i put this together so we would
have it um at the very end of the
statement i think it's uh
it says the former president's
accountability under the law for the
right on the united states capital on
january 6 is incidental to his
responsibility and accountability for
his attempt to steal the 2020
presidential election from the american
people and thereby steal america
america's democracy from herself so
michael what what do you make of that
statement from the judge there that
we're going to hear from today uh the
honorable
j michael ludwig yeah look it's a very
powerful statement i think it's um
accurate you know and there's i mean
look the the statement obviously speaks
for itself and he's obviously speaking
from knowledge i mean this isn't
something that's being concocted out of
the air this is a very thoughtful which
judge ludwig is he's a thoughtful uh
justice and
it's accurate i mean there's no other
way to put it however you know again
one of the biggest questions that i keep
hearing from people that i meet on the
street or people who reach out whether
it's journalists etc
is that do you think donald will ever be
held accountable
for any of these actions or are we just
wasting our time with these hearings and
again this is you know this is um tough
stuff this is no different to me than
the mueller investigation and my hope is
that look i know
a lot of what the
um
january 6th committee has in terms of
information um for me you know i've
spoken to several people who have
already now testified before them i
myself have testified not before january
6 but through nine different committees
and i understand the way that they
question as well and many of these folks
that have been questioned i've spoken to
so
i kind of have a little bit of a of a
better understanding than most however
again it's going to be a very difficult
lift and now that lift rests in the
hands of merrick garland and all we can
do is hope that he has the gumption
within which to hold trump and all of
these acolytes accountable for
an attempt to steal democracy um for the
destruction of you know of our democracy
and placing democracy in peril
michael thank you for your insight and i
hope you uh continue to join us um
through these hearings it's been great
to hear from you
leading into the coverage of these i
actually want to go to someone who knows
about holding trump accountable um
she's she's known as the trump
nda killa um so michael i'm gonna go to
her i appreciate you joining us stick
around watch this hearing see what you
think thank you michael cohen thanks for
joining us you got it tony
uh again i want to bring in the trump
nda killa killa killa jessica denson uh
jessica how are you um this morning uh
where you're at i believe you're out
there uh your mic is still muted there
jessica if you could unmute for us
that would be helpful wouldn't it yes
how are you how are you doing well how
are you tony i'm i'm doing perfect so uh
michael cohen was talking about holding
trump accountable and you actually have
some experience at holding trump
accountable um but you also want to have
trump held accountable not just by the
select committee but also by the doj and
it seems like we're working closer and
closer to that i know some people are
you know
like michael brought up merrick garland
but i think graves the united states
attorney in the dc district is the one
that'll actually bring those charges
well he'll recommend and merrick garland
will approve or deny i guess um
to say in a simple but you have held
trump accountable in court so tell us
about your experience not just with
trump but the trump orbit and what it
looks like to hold these people
accountable if that's what the january 6
select committee wants to do
yeah well as you said i i nullify the
trump campaign nba in court and i have
good reason to believe this is the
boilerplate language with the language
that the trump campaign and the trump
organization was using for decades and
just think about this i brought this
forward as one woman if you don't know
my story i started off with no lawyer i
was entirely alone and i brought this
case forward proactively challenging
this nda in court and because of my
persistence and
moving forward on the right idea just
knowing that this nda had to be illegal
challenging it proactively we got a
historic precedent that this nda is
invalid and unenforceable now just think
about if somebody years before me had
come forward to challenge trump's ndas
think of if prosecutors in the past
scythe ants years ago with trump soho
had taken action to hold the trump
family accountable for fraud
think of all of the missed opportunities
of holding donald trump accountable and
where we would be if he had been held
accountable in the past
we have the opportunity of our lifetime
facing us right now and we cannot miss
this opportunity we had opportunities
during the trump trump presidency
in impeachment one
and we could have removed the danger
that donald trump trump posed to this
country then
now is
is the grand finale we absolutely cannot
let this moment pass us
merrick garland lisa monaco matthew
graves
a lot of people say there's a lot of
pressure on them i think this is
this is the greatest
opportunity and and
i would i would love to be in their
position i hope they do not have fear
look at me i did it as one woman with no
support coming forward challenging trump
in court it was not easy i had to fight
back a fifty thousand dollar judgment
against me but in the end i came out
victorious and and if we come come
forward with the truth and are not
afraid and hold donald trump finally
accountable for his crimes
we're going going to save our democracy
this is what's going to do it and i hope
that they feel the support of these
hearings the truth coming forward the
american people being invested and
caring about the results
and that this segues into the
appropriate prosecutions for donald
trump
so what do you think today then um
creeps more forward towards that
accountability that you're talking about
because it seems like in this statement
from the judge that he's clearly saying
it's not just about the riot like this
is not just about the riot this is about
the former president of the united
states literally trying to take over our
country um and not in so many ways those
are my words not his uh i i pulled the
quote up earlier you've probably seen it
there so what do you make of what this
judge i mean what do you think he's
going to say you think
by by way of telling mike pence in
january of 2021 saying this is
unconstitutional you cannot do this
do you
do you think that judge is going to make
you know the
assertion that donald trump broke the
law criminally i mean
i think i think we can expect as the
theme of this committee has been for
them to make the connection that donald
trump was notified that these attempts
to pressure mike pence were illegal he'd
not think that his activity trying to
push this coup this insurrection was
something that was above board he knew
that it violated the law and when
michael was talking you know i was
listening to him talk like he usually
does about how donald trump is always
trying to keep his hands clean this is
how mob bosses work right right right
but let's just let's just step back for
a minute here i mean we're always we're
trying to find the connection where's
the where's the conspiracy where's the
connection from donald trump to the
proud boys or the eastman
okay
none of these people not the proud boys
not john eastman not rudy giuliani
nobody is acting without the sitting
president of the united states signaling
that he wants to overthrow the will of
the people nobody is acting without him
doing that
and he i would argue that he did it
going way back as as far as you know
early 2020 when he said the election was
going to be rigged but on election night
when he said in fact we've won this
election and when he continued to
challenge it he was constantly signaling
from the tweet that this is wild
i'm i'm no lawyer but i've played one
hell of a good one against the trump the
trump orb
i would argue that what is in the public
record is is sufficient evidence to
establish the nexus between donald trump
and all of the coup attempts and
kudos to the january 6 committee and the
phenomenal work they are doing to bring
these salient details out to draw these
lines so i think the judge um is is
definitely going to help to make the
connection in in
in that line
well jessica thanks for joining us and
please if you can stick around we'll
have a break i'm sure in between this
hearing and if you want we will we will
be covering um the hearing afterwards
i'd love to hear what your take is once
we hear the evidence um so stick around
if you can thank you jessica for joining
us again everyone go follow jessica on
twitter she is she is the woman who
paved the way
uh to kill the trump nda the
the official
trump nda killa and thank you jessica
thank you for joining us
i'm gonna go to michael popock michael i
think he's ready there give me a thumbs
up if you're ready um okay good and
michael popock uh how are you this
morning
oh
it's it's a wonderful day to be in a
democracy when you
bring sunshine as an antiseptic to all
the bad criminality of the trump
organization and trump
sure so let me ask you because um we've
we've seen some statements this morning
um and i'll bring one up on the screen
here from the judge that we're going to
hear from today of course i have some
excerpts here but the main one is that
last paragraph i read the first part of
the paragraph but let me read the last
part of that paragraph it says this said
will for ignorance of law and the fact
is neither excuse nor defense in law
will for ignorance thus
is neither political nor legal excuse or
defense available to the former
president united states his allies and
his supporters what do you what do you
what do you make of this i mean this is
good get ready get ready for judge
ludwig
let me give you and i up uh pre-game
talked a little bit about
the main witnesses today
can i do that yeah go ahead tell us
about these witnesses
yeah today is the hang mike pence day
this is the day
when the john 6 committee is going to
focus on the tremendous pressure being
brought on mike pence and all those
around him including his attorneys
in-house and outside by john eastman and
others in the trump campaign in order to
execute no pun intended another player
they love these names we had the green
bay sweeped by peter navarro trying to
get all of the state legislators to come
up with phony electors and send them to
mike pence but in order for that plan to
work john eastman came up with a
brilliant idea that mike pence was the
president temporary of the senate so
they had the president of the senate
plan which was tied to mike pence why is
trump asking to have mike pence hanged
and agreeing with people that said so
because in order to execute this
last-gasp effort to knock over democracy
they needed mike pence to go along
and the reason mike pence did not go
along besides his own personal
convictions is he was surrounded by
lawyers
and adults
and courageous people who told him the
truth
unlike donald trump who counted himself
with syncophanes
and drunks who told him whatever he
wanted to hear so the people in the
orbit for mike pence that we're going to
hear about today
is a guy named greg jacobs who was
basically the in-house general counsel
for mike the vice president's office
from mike pence we're going to hear
about richard cullen who was a mutual
friend of both
uh greg jacobs and mike pence and judge
luddick judge ludwig only came on to the
scene for mike pence
and in in jan 5 jan 6 and jan 7. so i
don't want people to think well michael
luddick former former fourth circuit
uh
um
judge and right wing
federalist society
conservative justice and judge and
lawyer there's no doubt about it his
words have power and meaning because he
has been on the gop side forever and on
the scalia
and on the thomas and on the originalist
federalist society right-wing
wing of the party this is not some
outlier this is not ronald reagan's son
this is the bluest
deepest of republicans who told mike
pence in no uncertain terms that his
former law clerk
john eastman who was a law clerk for
michael ludding
is full of [ __ ]
and that he should not there is no
constitutional or electoral act law that
allows the vice president to reject and
not count the electoral ballot in front
of him in fact michael luddig told mike
pence
that the electoral act of
of 18 whatever is unconstitutional
because there is no role for congress
in certifying who won the election other
than a clerical ministerial act of yay
and may and that's it unless there's not
a majority of electors in favor of one
party or the other or one person or the
other then it goes to house legislators
and he told mike pence and he told greg
jacobs
in no uncertain terms as a former
federal judge an originalist a
federalist that mike pence would be
committing treason if he interpreted the
constitution and the electoral act in
the way that john eastman was urging him
why did that why did he have power
because of who michael luddig is
just to give you an example tony and for
the audience michael luddig
was very close to warren berger on the
supreme court
he worked in the office of the white
house council under george bush he was a
handler
for
for uh clarence thomas the candidate
clarence thomas to get his seat on the
supreme court so he was basically
clarence thomas's lawyer he had
40 of his law clerks from the fourth
circuit court of appeal
ended up on the supreme court as clerks
33 of them served for either antonin
scalia or clarence thomas he was
considered a feeder program onto the
supreme court from the right right wing
and the federalist this is not a clown
this is not an outlier this is why
he
is being brought forward today and you
saw the public statement and just a
couple of things you didn't quote or you
haven't quoted yet
in his statement today
he
two things that struck me that are that
are powerful and are going to resonate
from this hearing
one is one is that he believes there
were many cowards on the battlefield of
january 6th but the vice president was
not one of them because at the end he
did the right thing
and that american democracy was almost
stolen from us as a result of jan six
and jan sixth
is not just
a violent overthrow insurrectionist in
his view it was the last step
in what in what uh
cheney is referred to as a seven part
plan
to overthrow the election and to cling
to power as a coup
for michael luddig
chad sixth
was the last violent attempt to execute
the plan to cling to power and i don't
know tony if you saw this
but there is and the and the committee
has released it
there is an exchange between john
eastman
and another lawyer ken cheesebro who is
pro-trump in december in which they said
they wanted chaos
on jan 6
in order to send a message to the
supreme court listen to this tony the
gen 6 was not just an isolated violent
overthrow attempt it was a messaging by
the crazies team abnormal within the
trump organization in orbit
to send a message to the supreme court
that more chaos would ensue unless they
started ruling in trump's favor and why
is that
why is that given added credence tony
because eastman told cheeseboro that he
has it on good authority that the
supreme court justices are worried about
this and will it will listen to violence
because he's close to
thomas and he's close to ginny thomas i
mean this whole thing i don't know if a
lot of gets into that today but this
whole thing that jan 6
is not just what the republicans wanted
it's nobody we're tired of hearing about
gen six there's gen six fatigue no the
american people want to move on
and and uh ludding's gonna look the
american people in the eye today and say
do not move on from january 6th right we
almost lost our democracy on that day
so speaking of uh clarence thomas's wife
jeannie thomas because we see
news not just tax medals to mark meadows
but
i think 29 state legislators in arizona
now she's been um i guess caught
emailing
uh q and on conspiracy theories to john
eastman i guess you know and this goes
on and on and we've seen benny thompson
the chairman of the january 6 select
committee this morning uh saying in so
many words yeah we want her to sit down
to talk to us um what do you make of
that movement that that the chairman is
willing to say yeah we need the supreme
court justice clarence thomas which by
the way if you can remind everybody what
the decision was for the information
that was given to the select committee
and which which justice actually was the
only one to say no i i don't i don't
want you to have that information so
what do you make of this clearance
namaste yeah in an eight to one decision
the supreme court ruled that the
national archive was empowered and was
entitled to turn over the the
information that jan 6 committee was
looking for from the white house the one
loaning the loan dissent was from
clarence thomas
at the time it was like isn't that
interesting but not surprising but then
we learn about jenny thomas out trying
to overturn elections by arguing the
fake the fake elector scandal and now we
know about the link between eastman a
former clarence thomas clerk so let's
get this straight he was a law clerk for
both michael luddig who's going to
testify today and clarence thomas so he
he told people that he had an insider
knowledge and a line of communication
into the supreme court which is supposed
to be completely insulated from politics
and from communication with the outside
world that's what that's what chief
justice roberts wants you to believe
that's what clarence thomas wants you to
believe when he gives his speeches
around the country but the reality is
that either eastman's full of [ __ ] and
lied to everybody in his orbit about his
connections to the supreme court through
jenny thomas and clarence thomas or he
has those connections and that makes
this even more poignant the that jan
sixth had many audiences it was an
attempt to stop the count it was an
attempt to buy time for john eastman to
execute his plan his president of the
senate plan his green suite plan through
doc when i say eastman i mean trump
eastman on behalf of trump right it was
it was the fight it was to buy time for
the supreme court to see what was
happening outside their doors and to
have that impact their decision making
so it is not an isolated you know a
bunch of wackadoos got together with
pitchforks and tried to attack our
capital as part of a systemic
plan a methodical well-thought-out plan
led by trump
to execute what what um
jamie raskin has called
a coup a coup in plain sight and and the
other people that are testifying today
and for which we'll hear clips from
include greg jacobs the general counsel
from mike pence who told john eastman as
the attack was ongoing in a text
look what you have done
your [ __ ] this is his quote
paraphrase has created an attack on the
capital putting all of our lives at risk
and john eastman to his credit as a
crazy wrote back no it's not that it's
that your boss mike pence won't execute
the plan that we've designed so greg
jake greg jack is going to talk about
that i think you're going to see clips
today tony because sometimes when the
committee tweets out who they're going
to have for live they don't talk about
the other video i think we're going to
see today mike pence's chief of staff
who testified under oath that he told
the secret service
that the president with his comments
about hanging mike pence has put the
vice president in harm's way and to make
sure that he is protected
and that nothing happens to him to
execute his constitutional duties to
count the electoral votes we're also
going to hear i believe today from eric
hirschman
because they released the clip already
from eric hershman who was a trump white
house lawyer
former formerly in private practice with
another trump lawyer named mark kasowitz
and and eric hirschman is the one who
got a phone call from eastman who said
we want to preserve evidence in georgia
this is on jan 6 and gen 5. we want to
preserve evidence in georgia and
hirschmann told him in very colorful
language are you [ __ ] out of your
mind and the next two words i want to
hear out of your mouth john eastman our
orderly transition say it he made he
said right he made him say it right and
then told him to get him get get you a
[ __ ] lawyer is basically what i mean
i'm going to give you the next best
piece of advice for free you've ever
gotten
get yourself a [ __ ] great criminal
defense lawyer because you're gonna need
it and that was the last phone call he
ever took from john because he knew he
knew they committed crimes right this
this is this is obvious it's on its face
right i mean it's another republican
white house trump lawyer so you're going
to hear from eric hershman you're going
to hear from mike luddig you're going to
hear from greg jacobs
right and then
and then you're going to see clips from
everything else so today is all about
hang mike pence pressure on mike pence
and the president and the president of
the senate plan that john eastman on
behalf of donald trump attempted to
execute and that's going to take up
until a full two hours well michael
popock i appreciate you joining us again
if you can stick around i know you have
some stuff that you have to do but if i
can bring you in at any time um during a
break or something if you're here i'll
try to bring you in to see what you're
hearing from the
um the hearing so thank you for joining
us everyone go um follow legal af on
wednesdays and saturdays on the midas
media network thank you michael i'm
gonna go to texas now we're gonna go
we're gonna go see what's going on in
texas
we're going to get
texas paul's take on this everyone loves
texas paul with the midas media network
so texas paul how are you
i'm excited i'm i am incredibly fired up
i am incredibly fired up i uh just three
quick points one going back to what
jessica denson was saying about
merrick garland
when mayor garland was
first uh
when obama first
announced that he was going to nominate
him for the supreme court i knew nothing
about merrick garland i went back and
became a merrick garland expert i
wouldn't look at everything he did on
the dc court of appeals and i will tell
you
what will take donald trump down
he may be insulated for all of what
we're talking about now but what will
bury donald trump will be the legal
defense fund
because you cannot defraud people
you know a little boilerplate language
hidden down at the bottom in the small
fine print saying i get to steal your
money
is not protection from fraud he openly
defrauded his supporters
of 250 million people in the testimony
of 250 million dollars and the testimony
we've heard so far
absolutely confirms that donald trump is
going to jail and i will bet you this
hat it is for fraud
and well that carries a long a lot of
jail time you you heard it here from
from texas paul
i'll tell you uh paul i actually i i'm
i'm not going to disagree with you here
i think there's also civil suits that
are going to come class action against
um the when these folks really start to
find out that they were defrauded not
just by donald trump but the rnc because
part of this money went to the rnc no
legal defense fund to be found i believe
there's going to be even uh
not just maybe criminal but also
financial consequences for this what do
you what do you make though of the mike
pence stuff today michael popock said
this is all going to focus around pence
today so what do you make of this i know
there's something that you kind of had
you kind of had in your your hat there
as you said of what this mike pence was
and how he changed his statement and did
he change his statement that he was
going to make that day the language that
was used but really you know the other
thing i i really want america to know
and i hope we get the answer to
is why mike pence didn't get into that
secret service van in the parking garage
with mark short i hope we hear some of
that today but what do you make of this
mike pence stuff what do you make of it
mike pence didn't get that car he was
keeping his hands clean
uh if you listen to everything that
that's going to be talked about today
mike pence was not kept out of the loop
they absolutely had
in-depth discussions about what they
wanted to do
mike pence
added language
to this process
that both one covered his butt but then
during the actual certification process
i believe is where the real coup attempt
was happening if you go back to the 2000
election
which was a truly contested election
came down to like 237 votes in one state
that that's that's a dead tie
the recount was a [ __ ] show
al gore added to the end of the
certification
for each state are there any objections
no one else has added that language in
modern history until mike pence did it
and they had and you know from the
testimony we've had
to date there was no legal reasoning for
them to believe that they actually had
any disputable facts
but he added that objection
anyways
so i don't think mike pence actually
didn't go along with it i think he went
along with it in the way that kept his
hands clean and kept him from being the
one that broke the law
i don't think that you know
mike pence was on
team justice i think mike pence was on
team let's not be stupid and get thrown
in jail for the rest of our lives
i i i tend to agree with you i i i think
we're gonna hear that today that
and i don't know if we're gonna
get evidence of this or not but it seems
to me that mike pence was looking around
a lot for a reason to do what eastman
and trump wanted him to do even even
went to the guy that couldn't spell
potato right he went to he went to dan
whale and he's like can i do this and
dang well's like not just no but hell no
you can't do this even the guy who
couldn't smell potato
may have may have had a
something to do with saving our
democracy so but i do not believe that
mike pence did not cooperate i think he
did cooperate with donald trump in that
way because you think about the number
of objections that went to debate
during that whole time and that goes to
the third point i was going to make
i don't think the coup was supposed to
occur
in the legislature
i think this was a delaying tactic they
thoroughly expected if you look at every
other in
um
uh every other time that that the white
supremacists have thrown a rally who
showed up
every single time right
was antifa they went blm we went out
there we counter protested
you've heard from the proud boys you've
heard from the oath keepers that they
were told from somebody in the white
house and this is the back channel goes
back to mike what michael cohen was
talking about that they were going to be
deputized as a militia they that's why
donald trump sat there for three hours i
guarantee you he was waiting for us to
show up so that he could declare a state
of emergency blame it on blm and antifa
i mean fox already had talking points
that they were running
during the insurrection saying it was
antifa and blam
right well and then they had him
but then they had to backtrack then they
had to backtrack and you know i think i
think because we didn't show up that's
right that's right well and because
of a good reason there was no reason to
go to an insurrection because no i don't
think anyone really expected that that
donald trump would actually overthrow
the government of the united states but
he certainly tried and i think we're
going to find out what mike pence's role
was in that today
and i i will tell you i absolutely 100
percent believe
that's why mike pence didn't leave
i don't think he's clear of this i think
he participated i think he participated
in a way that nobody's really looking at
he was part of the delaying tactic they
were
i mean because if you look at everything
everything involved with this
caches of weapons real active
ready-to-go bombs
that were planted
they were ready right to declare a state
of emergency well and that would have
that happened had we showed up
donald trump would be our president
right now well i think i think i think
you're getting to acts of war even uh
which brings up the big t word uh thank
you paul for joining us i'm going to
bring in a couple fellows here that you
may know uh the mizellas brothers uh ben
myself and brett mizellis are joining us
how are you fellas
good how are you tony i'm doing great
the uh live streamers ready for this
historic day well let me let me show you
something here we have the uh we have
the committee room now now streaming
here um it that there's a little bit of
activity from the press here they
haven't made their way in there yet uh
we still have about 15 20 minutes but
what's your guys's take on this i want
to go to david bender and my co-host
gabe sanchez and see what they think
here to lead us in but what what's your
guys's take on on the statements that
have been released today but some of the
news that has dropped um just in recent
hours here what do you make of all this
well i'll speak first then i'll leave it
to brett you have to read that 12-page
judge michael luddig
uh opening statement that he's prepared
to make today
that
i was speechless after i read that that
was a takedown of this fake bs
uh mega republicanism
mind you judge michael lettig is known
as one of the most prominent
conservative
jurists he's a retired fourth circuit
federal judge as high as you go before
the supreme court um someone whose name
was always talked about as being a
possible supreme court justice and
here's someone who just took down and
absolutely page by page calls out trump
as being a criminal as being someone who
threatened and attempted to overthrow
our democracy so we're going to hear
from judge michael ledeck today we're
also going to hear from greg jacob vice
president pence's former council he's
now in private practice and greg jacob
was the lawyer who had reached out to
john eastman who also happens to be a
lawyer i say that though
anything that eastman did was not
lawyer-like he's actually a criminal
co-conspirator of donald trump and said
that uh because of your [ __ ] this is
what greg jacob says to uh eastman
because of your [ __ ] the capital is
now under siege so today is going to be
even more dramatic in blockbuster than
the prior two hearings by leaps and
bounds well i i i agree with you i think
there's going to be some blockbuster
stuff and some bits of news uh
bret i know you're gonna probably be
making clips of this and posting it all
over social media so what are you
looking for what what are those key
things
what do you think these sound bites are
that maybe americans can digest because
we know
that the majority of america
unfortunately unfortunately isn't going
to digest the entire hearing uh like we
saw with the johnny depp and amber her
trials they like those little kits clips
so what are you looking for what do you
think is going to be those sound bites
that come out of this from this witness
testimony but also from the testimony
that is pre-recorded that they'll play
and to your point tony that's why these
little clips are so important and that's
why social media and us all getting out
the message is so important here because
these little clips the moments that you
see today at the january 6th hearings
those moments that you send to your
friends that you post on twitter that
you post on facebook that you share on
tick tock that you add your commentary
to these are how most of the american
public is going to digest this content
and that is truly what will sway public
opinion it's going to be you having
conversations with your family and your
friends and letting them know exactly
what happened and the stakes of what is
going on because january 6 was not a
one-time event january 6 is an ongoing
threat to our country that threatens
everything it threatens all issues of
our life and yes that includes gas
prices that includes inflation that
includes social security and medicare
literally all of these issues are on the
line if we don't even have our democracy
so these are incredibly important
hearings i think with these clips what
i'm looking for is not only the message
itself the message itself is quite
important but the messengers are also
perhaps more important and that's why
the people who they are having testify
today are so important they are such
important witnesses they are such
important people being these republicans
being people who have been conservatives
their entire life issuing these searing
indictments of the current elected
republican party i think that right
there is going to be incredibly powerful
once we hear the actual pressure
campaign about mike pence i think we're
going to start to connect the dots there
to everything that was going on and i
think that's going to include john
eastman i think today we've already
found out last night that this will
include ginny thomas that this is going
to include a whole cast of characters
and if you remember a federal judge has
already stated that eastman's conduct
was more likely than not criminal
behavior and he said that about eastman
and he said that about trump so if you
have somebody like a ginny thomas also
in the mix there then i think you can
infer that jenny thomas's behavior if
she was covering the same sort of issues
was also probably more likely than not
criminal behavior so i want to get to
the bottom of this i too like ben i
really respected that statement from
judge ludwig i thought it was incredibly
powerful i think that is one for the
history books and in it he invoked the
civil war which i think was interesting
almost positioning this current moment
in our history as sort of a cold civil
war invoking statements from lincoln's
gettysburg address throughout that
statement and i think those words are
powerful and i hope that there are at
least some republicans looking and
realizing that they will not only be
judged now but that history will judge
them as well in the future as to where
they stand right now but i will add if
mike pence was really
this honorable figure and not cowardly
and i do think mike pence did the right
thing there but i think if mike pence
really wanted my respect he would be
there in that room today testifying
alongside luddig alongside greg jacob i
i want to say
one other thing though the one of the
funniest things though is
you know john luddig is as conservative
using the term conservative and a
republican as you can get and these
people are so steeped in this donald
trump maga cult that they call out the
preeminent conservative jurist as being
a rhino that's right or elected the fact
that john ludwig is being called the
leftist tells you just how
utterly ridiculous this maga movement
how disingenuous and how utter culty it
ultimately is because it's the same
putin propaganda right i mean you just
literally go the complete opposite way
you have like the single most
conservative jurist out there but no
he's a woke lib that's a woke that's the
woke left it's like shut the [ __ ] back
let me tell you something let me tell
you something i would love to be a fly
on mike pence's head uh in some of those
meetings with the judge because i almost
i i think i'm with you ben that the
judge is probably just as or more
conservative quote unquote than the
former vice president who
was looking for a way or if he could
overturn this election i mean i think
he's probably more conservative than
mine than what we think of conservative
is mike pence don't i mean wouldn't you
agree i mean
what the judge says in his 12-page
uh you know statement also is if this
was like a you know what that what the
trump john eastman plan was if this was
like brought up in a first year law
school class
as a hypothetical it would be viewed as
treasonous and um the fact that this was
brought to a sitting president of the
united states you know is beyond
the consciousness right and not only
just not only just a president but trump
the president who was just a buffoon and
looking for any way to to keep himself
in the power um guys i want to go to
david if you can stick around i'm going
to go to david bender and gabe i'm going
to bring gabe in here too um because
david i think you can speak to what's
going to happen today in in this hearing
um as far as these witnesses and what
we're going to see what do you think
david well i got my walter winchell hat
on and that means nothing to anybody but
uh it's it's stylish today david how
about i'm good
listen uh judge ludwig is uh is crucial
and in ways that are going to really
ripple they're
calling them a rhino is is real is going
to be one of the more
ridiculous things for them to try
because
uh his clerks included ted cruz
and john eastman
so
wait until the twitter stuff happens and
they try and knock him down
if you're talking about the clips
that you can pull brett
uh it's the first line
a stake was driven through the heart of
american democracy on january 6 2021 and
our democracy today is on a nice edge
we're going to hear that in just a
little while from judge ludwig and
you can't
there's no way of
uh
missing the importance of what he says
and taking that out of context
our democracy is on a nice edge
so
judge ludwig's going to be very
important
uh you referenced
the vice president's council greg jacob
he was in the room
when trump
turned the screws on mike pence
and
said
if you don't do this you're a [ __ ]
uh whether they say that uh we've gotten
[ __ ] from uh billboard we've both
been from biltmore for a year they said
the f-word too they said the f-words
they have maybe maybe they'll use it
through it it did i don't think we're
going to get that today but we know it
as a matter of fact that the pressure on
pence
was unbelievable and using language like
that from the president to the vice
president and that is something in a
much more elegant way we're going to see
judge ludwig
referred to today
is the kind of pressure now what he does
what he does is really important is he's
teeing up
pence
all of us can say
pence uh may not have been a hero who's
looking for a way out he was asking
other people uh what he could do to
do what he'd always done for four years
anything donald trump wanted he was
looking for a way but when he found that
there wasn't one
he did do the right thing
and that's what everyone is teeing him
up
to hear from this committee liz cheney
started it that way on the first hearing
talking about the judgment we're going
to hear that a lot today about how much
integrity he showed how strong he was
so why why is that going to happen
i think they're fishing
i think they're trying to throw a line
in the water to get mike pence to show
up
i don't know if he's gonna fight but
that's what this is about
i'll say this also uh to add to that i
said we all know the jokes about oh to
be a fly on mike pence's head in that
specific moment well today i think we'll
be as close as we will actually get to
getting the perspective of the fly on
mike pence's head as the insurrection
was going on and so i'm excited to hear
that inside perspective i i i have a
swatter here in case
[Laughter]
this this
this is this is one
and truly
you've all read the 12-page statement
now
it's going to be quoted for as you said
been recorded for a long time
but there are moments in here that when
they are clipped
there's no way the news won't lead with
it the mainstream news but it's gonna
it's gonna hit the republicans there's
no way it can't
this is a guy whose credentials are
beyond reproach
and that'll be where they're on the spot
when people go to ted cruz and ask him
what do you think of ludwig
he will not throw him under the bus uh
maybe maybe he will ted cruz is
shameless as we know but i i think not i
think they'll be quiet
because this is one of those moments
where
one of their own in fact their mentor
is telling them that they led an
insurrection to overthrow
the constitution and it shows you just
how far away they've really gotten from
actual conservatism as we say as
listeners of the midas touch podcast
will know and i urge everybody who's
watching this to go subscribe to the
midas touch podcast
these republicans today are just not
conservative in any way and so when you
have somebody like a luddite go out
there and speak and actually espouse can
real conservative principles it shocks
the current republican establishment
that has gotten so far off course that
has veered so far to the right that
they've literally ended up in hungary at
doing cpac in hungary that's how far
they have gone to the right and so
finally you have a sensible conservative
actually come back into the picture and
what are these crazy ultra mega
republicans do they go woke left liberal
woke left crazy because everybody at
that point when you are so far to the
right everybody looks woke left and so i
hope that this is a huge shock to
anybody who actually dare call
themselves a conservative and shows them
that this is really what conservative
principles mean and this is really what
it means to abide by the constitution of
the united states you know i want to
bring in speaking of the mind as dutch
podcast i want to bring in the most
popular co-host of the uh
spot guest here um jordy jordy what what
are we just chop liver i'm out of here
all right yeah you know i i the polls
speak for themselves i don't know what
to tell you fellas
the polls are the bulls the banks are
the first hashtag free jordy you got to
let him out you know right right right
jordy um i i your mic is not working
your mic's um your mic's not working
there see this is why we didn't allow
jordan exactly this is exactly right
he's still popular even without the mic
right here
if you were to do a poll right now who
was the best speaker between the three
of us
based on that performance jordan
i bet you 80
jordy would go he showed up for a second
he tried i saw the
he really was pushing that right button
and it wasn't working well i did not
take him out of the broadcast i think
jordy got fed up with ben and left um
you know
everyone knows that why are you being
mean why are you guys being mentioned i
mean he shows up late number one number
very very very late number two it is
mike is not even working he's buffering
it's
but brett and ben are gonna get a phone
call from their parents tonight saying
why were you so mean to jordy on the air
hey gentlemen this is why i'm an only
child
okay the reason for it i just chose that
it works
yeah right
right
so i think we're uh we're nearing the
yes uh well we're here
i'm going to uh bring this up here it
looks like um some of the witnesses are
making their way into that's judge
ludwig right there
on our right and greg jacob uh
on the left
so we we will uh we will undo the uh
sound here in in just a minute to uh
start hearing that i want to tell
everybody right now before we remove the
sound go and send this youtube link
right now text it to your family and
friends go tweet it out go put it on
your facebook page let's make this the
most watched january 6th hearings yet
and get the message out to everybody
because i think it's i think it's going
to be a big one i really think it's
going to be big
here they're taking pictures with the
press gabe gabe what were you yeah i was
just gonna say i think this uh you know
this opening statement and kind of the
line of question are really gonna debunk
the whole legitimate political discourse
argument that the uh republicans have
made about january 6. i mean if there's
one thing this makes me envision right
now it's that meme
of the stressed out guy who's over the
controls and you have to either admit
that january 6th was a coup
or you have to say that judge ludwig is
is a hack and he's he's a liberal
leftist and he's part of the the deep
state right it's that it's that moment
of like
which one do i admit to the actual
conservative and he's not a conservative
or that the january 6 was a coup and i
think that's a struggle that we're going
to see a lot of people bring out
especially as as david brought up you
know you've got ted cruz right that that
was his mentor that was the person that
he worked for you had eastman who
obviously is a criminal
uh uh
is a criminal just by itself not a
lawyer just a criminal as ben pointed
out so
i think today will be very revealing
um even from the clips that we've
already seen leading up about mike pence
uh especially today so and gabe you
think about the other witnesses who have
testified and there are the previous
witness testimony has been more kind of
like sound bitey-ish like no witness has
really testified more than three to four
minutes each right but they've waited
strategically to have this judge let it
give the first real traditional
kind of statement that we're used to and
they've really planned it and done that
on purpose after setting the stage for
him to spend i mean look it's probably
going to take him if he's going to read
the full statements which i expect it's
going to be probably about 25 minutes to
get through you know that full statement
yeah they definitely yeah his words
with the other clips you know tony i
talked about on the show uh yesterday in
the day before is they've had these
sound bites which we've seen these
people that have been obviously been
interviewed for hours on end for their
depositions but the clips are really
only 30 seconds at a time right you see
a little bit of uh bar here you see a
little
of uh ivanka here like they're not the
major clips but they've got them
cataloged based on who the person is and
what they talked about so they can
easily reference them like we saw on
monday
you know we had uh
um
uh last minute you know removal of you
know um
a bill not able to make it so they're
like well pull clip 17 16 14. like
they're just going down the list they
were
ready to go whenever possible and i
think that's like you said setting up
for a longer kind of official statement
like this and i'm sure we'll have even
more clips that will come out of this
the chairman is uh
yes he is he's making his way
is is in
so we are uh
well uh fellas stick around for coverage
afterwards um let's get to the hearing
thanks thanks for thanks for joining us
here uh we will we will be
a quick
will be a break again they have built
that in
great great we'll we'll see you guys at
the break if you can um otherwise let's
get to the hearing here let's see
what the witness panel today is going to
say
about january six
the select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the united states
capitol will be in order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee in
recess at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material represented during today's
hearing
good afternoon
this is almost no idea more un-american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
no idea more un-american
i agree with that which is unusual
because former vice president mike pence
and i don't agree on much
these are his words spoken a few months
ago about donald trump's attempt
to pressure the former vice president
pressure him into going along with an
unlawful and unconstitutional scheme
to overturn the 2020 election
and give donald trump a second term in
office that he did not win
today the select committee is going to
reveal the details of that prussia
campaign
but what does
the vice president of the united states
even have to do
with the presidential election
the constitution says that the vice
president of the united states
oversees the process of counting the
electoral college votes
a process
that took place on january 6 2021
donald trump wanted mike pence to do
something no other vice president has
ever done
the former president wanted pence to
reject the votes
and either declare trump the winner or
send the votes back to the states to be
counted again
mike pence said no
he resisted the pressure
he knew it was illegal he knew it was
wrong
we are fortunate for mr pence's courage
on january 6th
our democracy came dangerously close to
catastrophe
that courage put him in tremendous
danger
when mike pence made it clear
that he wouldn't give in to donald
trump's scheme
donald trump turned the mob on him
a mob that was chanting
hang mike pence
a mob that had built a hangman's gallows
just outside the capitol
thanks in part to mike pence our
democracy was
stuart donald trump scheme
and the violence of january 6th
but the danger hasn't receded
led by my colleague mr aguilar
today we'll lay out the facts
for the american people
but first i recognize my colleague from
wyoming miss cheney for any opening
statement she care to offer
thank you very much mr chairman let me
take just a few minutes today to put the
topic of our hearing in broader context
in our last hearing we heard unequivocal
testimony that president trump was told
his election fraud allegations were
complete nonsense
we heard this from members of the trump
campaign we heard this from president
trump's campaign lawyers
we heard this from president trump's
former attorney general bill barr
we heard this from president trump's
former acting attorney general jeff
rosen
and we heard this from president trump's
former acting deputy attorney general
richard donahue
we heard from members of president
trump's white house staff as well
today we're focusing on president
trump's relentless effort to pressure
mike pence to refuse to count electoral
votes on january 6.
here again is how the former vice
president phrased it in a speech before
the federalist society a group of
conservative lawyers
for this week
that president trump said i had the
right to
overturn the election
but president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the american
people and the american people alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
america
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
what the president wanted the vice
president to do was not just wrong it
was illegal and unconstitutional
we will hear many details in today's
hearing but please consider these two
points first
president trump was told repeatedly
that mike pence lacks the constitutional
and legal authority to do what president
trump was demanding he do
this is testimony from mark short the
vice president's chief of staff
who served in the trump administration
in multiple positions over four years
but just to pick up on that mr short is
it was it your impression that the vice
president had directly conveyed his
position on these issues to the
president not just to the world through
a dear colleague letter but directly to
president trump many times
and had been consistent in conveying his
position to the president very
consistent okay
but president trump plotted with a
lawyer named john eastman to pressure
pence to do so anyway
as the federal court has explained quote
based on the evidence the court finds
that it is more likely than not that
president trump and dr eastman
dishonestly conspired to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021.
what exactly did president trump know
when exactly did president trump know
that it would be illegal for mike pence
to refuse to count electoral votes
here is one sample of testimony given by
one of the witnesses before us today the
vice president's general counsel
did john eastman ever
admit
or you know in front of the president
that his proposal would violate the
electoral contact
uh
i believe he did on the fourth
that was january 4th
two days before the attack on congress
a second point
please listen to testimony today about
all of the ways that president trump
attempted to pressure vice president
pence
including
donald trump's tweet at 2 24 pm
condemning vice president mike pence
when president trump already knew a
violent riot was underway at the capitol
in future hearings you will hear from
witnesses who were present inside the
white house who were present inside the
west wing on that day
but today we focus on the earnest
efforts of mike pence who was determined
to abide by his oath of office
as vice president pence prepared a
statement on january 5th and 6th
explaining that he could not illegally
refuse to count electoral votes he said
this to his staff
i mean the vice president had said this
may be the most important thing i ever
said
this means statement
he really wanted to make sure
that it was just
you will hear today that president
trump's white house counsel believed
that the vice president did exactly the
right thing on january 6th as did others
in the white house
as did fox news host sean
hannity vice president pence understood
that his oath of office was more
important than his loyalty to donald
trump
he did his duty
president trump unequivocally did not
thank you mr chairman i yield back
without objection i recognize the
gentleman from california mr aguilar for
an opening statement
thank you mr chairman
today we intend to show the american
people that january 6th was not an
isolated incident
in the weeks culminating before
it was a legal scheme
and deception
we've already learned that president
trump knew he lost the 2020 election
shortly after he began to look for a way
to circumvent our country's most
fundamental civic tradition
the peaceful transfer of power
the president latched on to a dangerous
theory
and would not let go
because he was convinced it would keep
him in office
we witnessed firsthand what happened
when the president of the united states
weaponized this theory
the capital was overrun
police officers lost their lives
and the vice president was taken to a
secure location
because his safety was in jeopardy
let's take a look at the effect of
donald trump's words and actions
i want to warn our audience that the
video contains explicit content
mike pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
and mike pence i hope you're going to
stand up for the good of our
constitution and for the good of our
country and if you're not i'm going to
be very disappointed in you i will tell
you right now
i'm telling you what i'm hearing the
pits
i hear in the pins just caved no
is that true i didn't i'm here i'm
hearing reports of pence cave
i'm telling you if pence came we're
gonna drag [ __ ] through the
streets
you [ __ ] politicians are going to get
[ __ ] drove through the streets
i guess the hope is that there's such a
show of force here that pence will
decide to do the right thing according
trump
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
how did we get to this point
how did we get to the point where
president trump's most radical
supporters
led a violent attack on the capitol and
threatened to hang president trump's own
vice president
you'll hear from witnesses that donald
trump pressured mike pence
to adopt a legally and morally bankrupt
idea that the vice president could
choose who the next president can be
you'll hear about how the vice president
the white house counsel and others told
donald trump that the vice president had
no such authority
but president trump would not listen
you'll hear how vice president pence was
stood in onslaught of pressure from
president trump both publicly and
privately
a pressure campaign that built to a
fever pitch with a heated phone call
on january 6th
you'll also hear
that the president knew there was a
violent mob at the capitol when he
tweeted at 2 24 pm that the vice
president did not have the quote courage
to do what needed to be done
let me be clear
vice president pence did the right thing
that day
he stayed true to his oath to protect
and defend the constitution
i look forward to hearing from our
witnesses this afternoon mr chairman i
yield back
thank you mr aguilar
we are honored to have two distinguished
witnesses
who advise vice president regarding his
role on january 6th judge j michael
ludwig is one of the leading
conservative legal thinkers in the
country
he served in administrations of
president ronald reagan and george h.w
bush
he was appointed by the latter to serve
on the u.s court of appeals for the
fourth circuit where he served from 1991
to 2006.
he provided critical advice for vice
president pence regarding the role of
the vice president in the joint session
of congress shortly before that faithful
moment
he's written that the vice president
does not have the power
to select the next president of the
united states
he's also written that con that contrary
theory espoused by one of his own former
law clerks was quote
incorrect at every turn
we're also joined today by one of the
people who was with vice president pence
on january 6.
greg jacob
was counsel to vice president pence he
conducted a thorough analysis of the
role of the vice president in the joint
session of congress under the
constitution the electoral account act
and 230 years of historical practice
but he also has firsthand information
about the attack on the capitol
because he lived through it
he was with vike the vice president and
his own life was in danger
i will now sweat in our witnesses
the witnesses will please stand and
raise their right hand
do you swear our firm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you you may be seated
let the record reflect the witnesses
answered in the affirmative
announce recognize myself for questions
in the united states the people choose
our representatives
including the highest official in the
land the president of the united states
the american people did this on november
3rd
2020
but president trump did not like the
outcome
he did everything he could to change the
result of the election he tried
litigation
62 cases in fact and that failed
he tried to pressure state legislatures
to reverse the results of the election
in their states
but they refused
he tried to enlist the department of
justice in his efforts to overturn
election results
but officials leading the department
refused to comply
so eventually he latched on to a
completely nonsensical and
anti-democratic theory that one man
his own vice president could determine
the outcome of the election
he wanted the vice president to
unilaterally select
the president
this theory that the vice president
could unilaterally select the president
runs completely contrary to our
constitution
our laws and the
entirety of our american experience
but that didn't stop
didn't matter to president trump
i would now like to explore
how president trump came to latch on to
this ridiculous legal theory
that the vice president can select the
president of the united states
mr jacob
how did this theory first come to your
attention
the first time that i had a conversation
with the vice president about the 12th
amendment and the electoral count act
was in early december around december
7th
the vice president called me over to his
west wing office and told me that he had
been
seeing and reading things that suggested
that he had a significant role to play
on january 6th
in announcing the outcome of the
election
he told me that he had been first
elected to congress in 2000 and that one
of his earliest memories as a
congressman was sitting in
on the 2001 certification
and he recalled that al gore
had gathered down a number of objections
that had been raised to florida
and he asked me
mechanically
how does this work at the joint session
what are the rules
and i told the vice president that
in fact i had a fairly good idea of how
things work that actually there aren't
rules that govern the joint session but
what there is
is a
provision of the constitution that's
just one sentence long and then an
electoral count act that had been passed
in 1887
and i told the vice president that i
could put a memo together for him
overnight that would explain the
applicable rules
so mr jacobs when you looked at this
theory
what did you conclude
so
we concluded that
what you have is a sentence in the
constitution that is inartfully drafted
but the vice president's first instinct
when he heard this theory
was that there was no way
that our framers
who abort concentrated power
who had broken away from the tyranny of
george iii
would ever
have put
one person particularly not a person who
had a direct interest in the outcome
because they were on the ticket for the
election
in a role to have decisive
impact on the outcome of the election
and
our review of text
history
and frankly just common sense all
confirmed the vice president's first
instinct on that point there is no
uh justifiable basis to conclude that
the vice president has that kind of
authority
thank you mr jacobs
we will hear more today about how
despite this conclusion by you and other
top
legal advisers the former president used
this discredited theory
in his campaign to pressure the vice
president
to decide the outcome of the
presidential election
i now recognize the gentlewoman from
wyoming miss cheney for questions
thank you very much uh mr chairman um
judge ludwig thank you as well for being
here with us today um
you um
issued a very important statement
earlier today uh which i urge all
americans to read and i'd like to ask
you judge about
one of the sentences in your statement
and ask if you could explain to us
the significance of it
you say had the vice president of the
united states obeyed the president of
the united states
america would immediately have been
plunged into what would have been
tantamount to a revolution within a
paralyzing constitutional crisis could
you elaborate on that for us judge
thank you
madam
vice chairman
um
that that passage in in my statement
this morning
uh
referenced the
the most foundational
concept
in america which is the rule of law
thus as i interpret your question
you're asking about
that foundational
truth
of these
united states
which we call america
the foundational
truth
is the rule of law
that foundational
truth
is
for the united states of america
the profound
truth
but it's not merely
the profound truth
for the united states
it's also
the simple
truth
the simple foundational truth
of the american republic
thus
in my view
the hearings being conducted
by this
select committee
are
examining that
profound truth
namely the rule of law
in the united states of america
the specific question of course before
you
and before the nation
not before me
is whether
that
foundational rule of law
was supremely violated
on january 6
2021
now
to the question specifically that you
asked
madam vice chair
i believe that
had
vice presidents pence
obeyed the orders
from his president
and the president of the united states
of america
during the joint session
of the congress of the united states
on
january 6
2021
and
declared
donald trump
the next
president of the united states
notwithstanding
that
then president trump
had lost the electoral college vote
as well as the
popular vote in the 2020 presidential
election
um
that declaration of donald trump as the
next president
would have
plunged america
into
what
i
believe
would have been tantamount
to a
revolution
within
a constitutional crisis
in america
which in my view
and i'm only one man
would have been
the first
constitutional crisis
since the founding of the republic
thank you very much judge um for your
solemn attention to these issues
and and for your
appearance here today um we're gonna
describe and discuss in detail
uh what happened
um and and as we do i'm gonna describe a
few of the details now
um
of some of the actions taken
by a gentleman named kenneth
cheeseborough
after the
electoral college met
and cast their votes on december 14th
actually the day before they met kenneth
cheeseboro sent a memo to rudy giuliani
the president's lead outside council
mr cheeseborough wrote to mayor giuliani
that the vice president is charged with
quote
making judgments about what to do if
there are conflicting votes close quote
mr cheeseborough wrote that when the
joint session of congress got to arizona
in the alphabetical list of states the
vice president should not count
the biden votes quote because there are
two slates of votes
his justification which we will learn
more about in our next hearing was that
a group of trump supporters in arizona
and other swing states
decided to proclaim themselves the true
electors for the state
creating two sets of electors
the official electors selected by the
state
and a group of fake electors
this document was ordered to be produced
to the select committee by a federal
district court judge
as you will see on the screen shortly
judge david carter wrote quote
the draft memo pushed a strategy that
knowingly violated the electoral count
act
the judge concluded that quote the memo
is both intimately related to and
clearly advanced the plan
to obstruct the joint session of
congress on january 6 2021
a few days later professor john eastman
took up this cause
eastman was at the time a law professor
at chapman university law school
he prepared a memo outlining the
nonsensical theory that the vice
president could decide the outcome of
the election at the joint session of
congress on january 6th
you will see
portions of this memo on the screen
in the first line
he wrote quote seven states have
transmitted dual slates of electors to
the president of the senate
but dr eastman goes on to rely on those
so-called dual slates of electors to say
that vice president pence could simply
declare president trump the winner of
the 2020 election
mr jacob were there in fact dual slates
of electors from seven states
no there were not
and just a few days after that dr
eastman wrote another memo this one
quote wargaming out several scenarios
he knew the outcome he wanted and he saw
a way to go forward if he simply
pretended that fake electors were real
you will see that memo up on the screen
now
here dr eastman says the vice president
can reject the biden electors from the
states that he calls quote disputed
under several of the scenarios the vice
president could ultimately just declare
donald trump the winner
regardless of the vote totals that had
already been certified by the states
however this was false
and dr eastman knew it was false
in other words it was a lie
in fact on december 19 2020 just four
days before dr eastman sent this memo
dr eastman himself admitted in an email
that the fake electors had no legal
weight
referring to the fake electors is quote
dead on arrival in congress
end quote
because they did not have a
certification from their states
judge ludig did the trump electors in
those seven states who were not
certified by any state authority have
any legal significance
congresswoman there there was um
no support
whatsoever
in either the constitution of the united
states
nor the laws of the united states
for
the vice president
frankly
ever
to count
alternative
electoral slates from the states
that had not been
officially certified
by the designated
state official
in the electoral count act
of 1887
i did notice
in
the passage from
mr eastman's memorandum
and i took a note on it
and correct me if i'm wrong
but
he said
in that passage
that there was
both legal authority
as well as
historical
precedent
i do know what
mr eastman was referring to
when he said that there was
historical precedent
for doing so
he was incorrect
there was no
historical precedent
from the beginning
of the founding
in 1789
that
even as
mere historical precedent
as distinguished from legal president
would support
the possibility of the vice president of
the united states
quote counting
alternative electoral slates that had
not been officially certified
to the congress
pursuant to the electoral count act of
1887.
i
would be glad
to
explain that historical precedent
if the committee
wanted but it would be a digression
thank you very much judge uh i know my
colleagues will be pursuing that issue
in more depth uh and now i'd like to
yield back mr chairman
thank you very much pursuant to section
5c 8 of house resolution 503 the chair
recognizes gentleman from california mr
aguilar and staff council mr john wood
for questioning
thank you mr chairman
we're fortunate to have a bipartisan
staff
senior investigative counsel john wood
previously served as united states
attorney in missouri under president
george w bush he and i will share
today's lines of questioning mr wood
thank you mr aguilar
judge ludwig i had the incredible honor
of serving as one of your law clerks
another person who did
was john eastman
and you've written that dr eastman's
theory that the vice president could
determine who the next president of the
united states is is in your words
incorrect at every turn could you please
explain briefly your analysis
it was my honor
mr wood
to have you serve with my walker
i could
answer that question
perfectly
if i had
at my disposal
either
mr eastman's
tweet
or my own
analytical tweet of september 21st
but i don't
but um
that said let me try to
um
remember the
analysis
of
mr eastman's analysis and judge i can
read to you and to the audience i think
what was a really key passage from your
very insightful analysis when you wrote
i believed that professor eastman was
incorrect at every turn of the analysis
in his january second memorandum
beginning with his claim that there were
legitimate competing slates of electors
presented from seven states you've
already addressed that issue but your
next sentence said continuing to his
conclusion that the vice president could
unilaterally decide not to count the
votes from the seven states from which
competing slates were allegedly
presented so what was your basis for
concluding that dr eastman was incorrect
in his conclusion that the vice
president could unilaterally decide not
to count the votes from these disputed
states
i understand
as i previously
stated in response to congresswoman
cheney
the
there was no
basis in the constitution or laws of the
united states
at all
for the theory espoused
by mr eastman
at all
none
with all respect to
my co-panelist
he said i believe in
partial response to one of the select
committee's questions
that
the single sentence in the
12th amendment
was he thought inartfully written
that single sentence is not
inartfully written
it was
pristine clear
that the
president of the senate
on january 6
the incumbent vice president of the
united states
had little
substantive constitutional authority
if
any at all
the 12th amendment
the single sentence
that mr jacob refers to
says
in substance
that
following the transmission of the
certificates
to the
congress of the united states
and under the
electoral count act of 1887
the archivist of the united states
that
the presiding
officer
shall
open
the certificates
in the presence
of the congress of the united states in
joint session
it then
says
unmistakably
not even that the
vice president
himself
shall
count the electoral votes
it
clearly says
merely
that
the electoral count votes
shall then be counted
it was the
electoral account act of 1887
that
um
that filled in if you will
uh
the
simple words of of of the 12th amendment
in order to
construct for the
country uh
a
process for the counting
of the the sacred
process
for the counting of the electoral
votes
from the states
that neither
our original constitution
nor even
the 12th amendment
had done
the
irony if you will
is that
from its founding
until 1887
in
when
congress passed the electoral count act
um
the nation had been in
considerable
turmoil
during
at least five of its presidential
elections
beginning
as soon
thereafter
from the founding
as eighteen hundred
so it wasn't for
almost a hundred years later
until the electoral count act was passed
so
[Music]
that's why in my view
that piece of legislation
uh
is
not only a work in progress
for the country
but at this moment in history
an important
work in progress that needs to take
place
that was
long-winded i understand
judge ludwig at the risk of
oversimplifying for the non-lawyers who
are watching is it fair to say that the
12th amendment basically says two things
happen the vice president opens the
certificates and the electoral votes are
counted is it that straightforward
i would not want that
to be my testimony before
the congress of the united states
the language
of the 12th amendment
is that simple
thank you judge
mr jacob i have a question for you uh i
believe during your deposition before
this committee
you said something to the effect of
you'd read every word written about the
12th amendment the electoral account act
and historical practice
i know in response to the chairman's
earlier question you gave your bottom
line conclusion but can you tell us a
little bit about the process that you
and your colleagues went through
of researching this issue and what
conclusion you came to after your
thorough research
so
you as a lawyer who's analyzing a
constitutional provision you start with
the constitutional text you go to
structure
you go to history so we started with the
text
we did not think that the text was quite
as unambiguous as judge ludig indicated
in part
we had a constitutional crisis in 1876
because in that year
multiple slates of electors were
certified by multiple slates
and when it came time to count those
votes
the antecedent question of which ones
had to be answered
that required the appointment of an
independent commission
um that commission had had to resolve
that question and the purpose of the
electoral count act of 1887
had been to resolve those latent
ambiguities now i'm in complete
agreement with judge ludwig
it is unambiguous that the vice
president does not have the authority to
reject electors there is no suggestion
of any kind that it does
there is no mention of rejecting or
objecting to electors anywhere in the
12th amendment
and so the notion that the vice
president could do that certainly is not
in the text
but the problem
uh that we had and that john eastman
raised in our discussions was
we had all seen that in congress in 2000
in 2004 in 2016
there had been objections raised to
various states
and those had even been debated in 2004
and so
here you have an amendment
that says nothing about objecting or
rejecting and yet we did have some
recent practice of that happening within
the terms of the electoral count act so
we started with that text and i recall
in my discussion with the vice president
he said
i can't wait to go to heaven and meet
the framers and tell them
the work that you did in putting
together our constitution is a work of
genius thank you it was divinely
inspired
there is one sentence that i would like
to talk to you a little bit about
so then we went to structure and again
the vice president's first instinct here
is so decisive on this question there's
just no way
that the framers of the constitution who
divided power and authority who
separated it out
who
had broken away from george
iii and declared him to be a tyrant
there was no way that they would have
put in the hands of one person the
authority to determine
who was going to be president of the
united states
and then we went to history we examined
every single electoral vote
count that had happened in congress
since the beginning of the country
we examined the electoral count act we
examined practice under the electoral
count and critically
no vice president in 230 years of
history had ever claimed to have that
kind of authority hadn't claimed
authority to reject electoral votes had
not claimed authority to return
electoral votes back to the states in
the entire history of the united states
not once had a joint session ever
returned electoral votes back to the
states to be counted
and in the
crisis of 1876
justice bradley
of the united states supreme court who
supplied the decisive final vote on that
commission had specifically looked at
that question and said
first the vice president clearly doesn't
have authority to decide anything and by
the way also does not have authority to
conduct an investigation by sending
things back out
for a public look at things so
the history was
absolutely decisive and again part of my
discussion with mr eastman was if you
were right don't you think al gore might
have liked to have known in 2000 that he
had authority to just declare himself
president of the united states did you
think that the democrat lawyers just
didn't think of this very
obvious quirk that he could use to do
that and of course he acknowledged al
gore
did not and should not have had that
authority at that point in time but so
text structure history i think what we
had was some ambiguous text
that common sense and structure would
tell you the answer cannot possibly be
that the vice president has that
authority as the committee already
played the vice president's remarks
there is almost no idea more un-american
than the notion that any one person
would choose the american president and
then unbroken historical practice for
230 years that the vice president did
not have such an authority
thank you i reserve the remainder of my
time
mr jacob you weren't the only one
who knew that the legal theory was wrong
though
here is what various advisors to the
president thought about that theory
you've been clear repeatedly with mr
meadows about you and the vice president
having a different view about his
authority on january 6 i believe i had
did mr meadows ever explicitly or
tacitly agree with you or say yeah that
makes sense okay
i believe that um
that mark did agree
what makes you say that
i believe that's what he told me
but
as i mentioned i think mark had told so
many people so many different things
that
it was not something that that i would
necessarily
accept it's okay well that means that's
resolved i say tell me more what he told
you about on this topic i think it was
that you know the vice president doesn't
have any broader role
and i think he was understanding that so
despite the fact that he may have said
other things to the president or others
to you he said he understands the vice
president has no role yes okay did he
say that to you several times a couple
of times
before january 6th yes
the way it was communicated to me was
that um
uh pastor bologna
thought the idea
was uh
was nutty and had uh at what point
uh confronted eastman uh basically with
the same sentiment pat expressed
his admiration for the vice president's
actions on the day of the sixth
and said that he concurred with the
legal analysis that that our team had
put together to reach
that point
it made no sense to me
that in all the protections that were
built into the constitution
for a president to get elected steps
that had to be taken
that the power to choose the next
president would be sitting at with the
vice president
do you know if mr clark or mr
um
morgan is it normal
viewed about that thought about that mr
eastman's advice yeah they thought he
was crazy
do you know if they ever expressed an
opinion on whether
they thought the vice president had the
power that john eastman said he did
uh
i know for a fact i heard both say that
his theory was crazy that there was no
uh validity to it in any way shape or
form and did they express that before
january 6
yes
to whom
i think anyone who would listen
okay uh what were your prior
interactions with eastman
he described for me
what he thought the ambiguity was in the
statute and he was walking through it at
that time and i said
hold on a second i want to understand
what you're saying you're saying that
you believe the vice president acting as
president of the senate
can be the sole decision maker as to
under your theory who becomes the next
president united states
and
he said yes
i said are you out of your f in mind
right and i know
that was pretty blunt
i said you're completely crazy i said
you're going to turn around
until
78 plus million people in this country
that your
theory is this is how you're going to
invalidate their votes because you think
the election was stolen
and i said they're not going to tolerate
that said you're going to cause riots in
the streets
and he said
worse the effect of there's been
violence in the history of our country
eric to protect the democracy or protect
the republic
in fact there was a risk that the
lawyers in the white house counsel's
office would resign
for example fox news host sean hannity
expressed concern that the entire white
house counsel's office could quit
as you can see from these texts
mr hannity wrote to white house chief of
staff mark meadows that quote
we can't lose the entire white house
counsel's office i do not see january 6
happening the way he is being told
a few days later on january 5th mr
hannity wrote to mr meadows that quote
i'm very worried the next 48 hours
pence pressure white house council will
leave
while sean hannity was apparently very
concerned about the possibility that the
white house council would resign in
protest of the president's effort to
force the vice president to violate the
constitution
some others close to the president were
more dismissive of the white house
counsel's position
here's what trump's son-in-law and
senior advisor jared kushner said
during his
deposition regarding the white house
counsel pat sipoloni's threats to resign
jared uh are you aware of um instances
where uh pat sabalone threatened to
resign i i kind of like i said my
interest at that time was on trying to
get as many pardons done uh and i know
that you know he was always
him and the team were always saying oh
we're going to resign we're not going to
be here if this happens if that happens
so
i kind of took it up to just be whining
to be honest with you
the president's own lead outside council
rudy giuliani also seemed to concede
that the vice president did not have the
authority to decide the outcome of the
election or send it back to the states
here's what white house attorney eric
hershman said about his call with mayor
giuliani on the morning of the sixth
the morning of january 6 i think he
called me out of the blue
right and i was like getting dressed
and
we had an intellectual discussion
about
eastman's east i don't know if it's
eastman's theory per se but the vp is
role
and
you know he it was asking me my view and
analysis and other practical
implications of it
and when we finished
he said
like i believe that you know you're
probably right
i think you thought were done that it
would be something he'd have to consider
if he was sitting on the bench
but he'd probably come down and that you
know
you couldn't interpret it or sustain the
argument long term
of course the fact that mayor giuliani
seemed to admit that the theory was
wrong did not stop him from going before
the crowd just a few hours later on
january 6th and saying the exact
opposite
here is mayor giuliani's speech at the
ellipse rally on january 6th
we're here just very briefly to make a
very important
two points
number one
every single thing
that has been outlined
as the plan for today
is perfectly legal
i have professor eastman here with me to
say a few words about that
he's one of the preeminent
constitutional scholars in the united
states
it is perfectly appropriate
given the questionable constitutionality
of the
election
counting act of 1887
that the vice president can cast it
aside
and he can do what
a president called jefferson did when he
was vice president
[Applause]
he can decide
he can decide on the validity
of these crooked ballots
or he can send it back
to the legislatures
give them
five
to ten days to finally finish
the work
and here's what dr eastman said in his
speech at the ellipse
on january 6th
and all we are demanding of vice
president pence is this afternoon at one
o'clock he let the legislatures of the
state look into this so we get to the
bottom of it and the american people
know whether we have control of the
direction of our government or not
[Applause]
even dr eastman knew his theory didn't
hold water
mr jacob
you discussed and even debated this
theory at length with dr eastman
did dr eastman ever tell you what he
thought the u.s supreme court would do
if it had to decide this issue
yes
we had an extended discussion an hour
and a half to two hours on january 5th
um and
when i pressed him on the point i said
john if the vice president did what you
were asking him to do we would lose nine
to nothing in the supreme court wouldn't
we
um and
he initially started it well i think
maybe he would lose only seven to two
um and after some further discussion
acknowledged well yeah you're right we
would lose nine nothing
i appreciate that in our investigation
the select committee has obtained
evidence suggesting that dr eastman
never really believed his own theory
let me explain
on the screen you can see a draft letter
to the president from october 2020
in this letter an idea was proposed that
the vice president could determine which
electors to count at the joint session
of congress
but the person writing in blue
eviscerates that argument
the person who wrote the comments in
blue wrote
the 12th amendment only says that the
president of the senate opens the
ballots in the joint session and then in
the passive voice that the vote shall
then be counted
the comments in blue further state
nowhere does it suggest that the
president of the senate gets to make the
determination on his own
judge ludwig does it surprise you that
the author of those comments in blue was
in fact john eastman
yes it does congressman
but let me
watching this unfold
let me try to unpack
what was
at the root
of
what i have called the blueprint to
overturn the 2020 election
and it is this
and i had foreshadowed this answer
in my earlier
testimony
to congresswoman cheney
mr eastman
from the beginning
said to the president
that there was both legal
as well as
historical precedent
for the vice president
to overturn the election
and what we've heard today
i believe
is is what happened within the white
house and elsewhere
as
all
the players
led by
mr eastman
got wrapped around the axle
by the
historical
evidence claim
by mr eastman
let me explain very simply
this is what i said would require a
digression that i would be glad to
undertake if you wished
in short
if i had been advising the vice
president of the united states on
january 6th
and even if
then
vice president
jefferson
and
even then
vice president
john adams
and even
then
vice president
richard
nixon
had done
exactly
what the president of the united states
wanted his vice president to do
i would have laid my body
across the road before i would have let
the vice president
overturn the
2020 election
on the basis
of that
historical precedent
but what
this body needs to know
and now
america needs to know
is that
that was
the centerpiece
of the plan to overturn the 2020
election
it was the
historical
precedent
in the years
and with the vice presidents that i
named
as congressman raskin understands well
and
the
the effort by mr eastman and others was
to
to drive that
historical precedent
up to and under
that single
sentence
single pristine
sentence
in the 12th amendment to the united
states constitution
taking advantage of
if you will
what many
have said
is the in artful wording
of that sentence in the 12th amendment
scholars
before 2020
would have used that
historical precedent
to argue
not that vice president pence could
overturn the 2020 election
by accepting
non-certified state electoral
votes but they would have
made arguments as to some
substantive
not merely
procedural
authority
possessed by the vice president of the
united states on on
the
statutorily prescribed day for counting
the electoral college votes
this is um
this is constitutional mischief
judge i think that's a i think there's a
good point and i think it kind of begs
the question
that if the vice president had this
power to determine the outcome of a
presidential election why hasn't it ever
been used before why hasn't that ever
happened why hasn't a vice president
simply rejected the outcome of an
election and declared someone else the
winner
and instead as the chairman mentioned in
his opening for over two centuries vice
presidents have presided over the joint
sessions of congress in a purely
ceremonial role
this even includes as mr jacob mentioned
vice president al gore for those of us
who are old enough to remember
the 2000 election came down to one state
florida
there were weeks of recounts and
litigation after the election and al
gore conceded
of course al gore was vice president at
the time
but he never suggested that he could
simply declare himself the winner of the
2000 election when he presided over the
counting of the electoral votes
let's hear what vice president gore said
when he described the situation he faced
in 2000
importance of the united states of
america in all of human history
uh in lincoln's phrase we still are the
last best hope of humankind
uh and
the choice between one's own uh
disappointment in your personal career
and upholding the
the noble traditions of america's
democracy it's a pretty easy choice when
it comes down to it
mr jacob
did dr eastman say whether he would want
other vice presidents such as al gore
after the 2000 election or kamala harris
after the 2024 election to have the
power to decide the outcome of the of
the election
so this was one of the many points that
we discussed on january 5th
he had come into that meeting trying to
persuade us that there was some validity
to his theory i viewed it as my
objective to persuade him
to acknowledge he was just wrong and i
thought this had to be one of the most
powerful
arguments i mean
john
back in 2000
you weren't jumping up and saying al
gore had this authority to do that you
would not want kamala harris to be able
to exercise that kind of authority in
2024 when i hope republicans will win
the election and i know you hope that
too john and he said
absolutely al gore did not have a basis
to do it in 2000
kamala harris shouldn't be able to do it
in 2024
but i think you should do it today
mark short told the select committee
that vice president pence consulted with
one of his predecessors vice president
dan quayle regarding the role of the
vice president
vice president quayle confirmed pence's
view that the role was purely ceremonial
mr shortage also told the committee that
he mr short received a call from former
house speaker paul ryan
here is mr short's description of his
conversation with speaker ryan
speaker ryan wanted to call and say you
know you don't have
any greater authority and i i said mr
speaker you you know mike you know he
doesn't you know he recognizes that and
we sort of laughed about it and he said
i get it and he later spoke to um the
vice president too to i think have the
same conversation
fortunately for the fate of our republic
vice president pence refused to go along
with president trump's demands that he
determined the outcome of the
presidential election
mr jacob what was the vice president's
reaction when you discussed with him the
theory that the vice president could
decide the outcome of the election
congressman as i testified the vice
president's first instinct
was that there was no way
that any one person particularly the
vice president who is on the ticket and
has a vested outcome in the election
could possibly have the authority to
decide it by rejecting electors or to
decisively alter the outcome by
suspending the joint session for the
first time in history in order to try to
get a different outcome from state
legislatures
despite the fact that the vice president
had a strongly held and correct view
that he could not decide the outcome of
the election
president trump launched a multi-week
campaign
of both public and private pressure to
get the vice president mike pence to
violate the constitution
here are some examples of the intense
pressure the vice president faced from
all sides
and what his chief of staff thought of
it
i hope mike pence comes through for us i
have to tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through
i won't like him quite as much
was it your impression that the vice
president had directly conveyed his
position on these issues to the
president not just to the world through
a dear colleague letter but directly to
president trump many times
and he'd been consistent in conveying
his position to the president very
consistent
i am i am aware of the fact that the
president was upset
with the way
uh pence acted
are we to assume that this is going to
be a climactic battle well i think a lot
of that depends on the courage and the
spine of the individuals involved that
would be a nice way to say a guy named
mike uh vice president mike pence
yes
i think we've been clear is what the
vice president's role was i think the
vice president made clear with the
president i think i've been clear with
mark mose i think the vice president is
going to throw down tomorrow and do the
right thing because like i said before
this is a time for choosing people are
going to look back at this moment
tomorrow and remember where every single
one of their elected officials were did
they vote for the rule of law and
getting these elections right or did
they give it away to the democrats and
the people who cheated and stole their
way through this election definitely in
the you know when i got back into town
to talk to like the fifth and the sixth
um the president was you know all the
attention was on uh what mike would do
or what mike wouldn't do the vice
president really was not wavering in his
commitment to what he what his
responsibility was and so yeah was it
was it painful sure
the president's pressure campaign
started in december
for example although the vice president
made his views clearly and unmistakably
known to the president and others in the
white house
on december 23rd
president trump retweeted a memo from an
individual named ivan reichlen entitled
operation pence card
that called on the vice president to
refuse the electoral college votes from
certain states that had certified joe
biden as the winner
president trump started his pressure
campaign in december
but he dialed up the pressure as january
6th approached
the testimony we have received in our
investigation indicates that by the time
january 4th arrived president trump had
already engaged in a quote multi-week
campaign
to pressure the vice president to decide
the outcome of the election
this had included private conversations
between the two leaders
trump's tweets and at least one meeting
with members of congress
we understand that the vice president
started his day on january 4th with a
rally in georgia for the republican
candidates in the u.s senate runoff
when the vice president returned to
washington he was summoned to meet with
the president regarding the upcoming
joint session of congress
mr jacob who attended that meeting
the attendees were the vice president
the president
mark short the chief of staff to the
vice president myself and john eastman
there was about a five minute period
where mark meadows came in on a
different issue
let's show a photo of that meeting
mr jacob
during that meeting between the
president and the vice president what
theories did dr eastman present
regarding the role of the vice president
in counting the electoral votes
during the meeting on january 4th
mr eastman was opining that there were
two legally viable arguments um as to
authorities that the vice president
could exercise
two days later on january 6th
one of them
was that he could
reject electoral votes outright
the other was that he could use his
capacity as presiding officer to
suspend the proceedings
and declare essentially a 10-day recess
during which
states that he deemed to be disputed
there was a list of five to seven states
that
um the exact number changed from
conversation to conversation
but that the vice president could
sort of issue a demand to the state
legislatures in those states to
re-examine
the election and declare
who had won each of those states so he
said that both of those were legally
viable options
he said that he did not recommend
upon questioning he did not recommend
what he called the more aggressive
option which was reject outright because
he thought that that would be
less politically palatable
the the imprimiter
of state legislature authority
would be necessary to ultimately
have
public acceptance of an outcome in favor
of president trump and so he advocated
that the preferred course of action
would be the procedural route
of suspending the joint session and
sending the election back to the states
mr jacob i know you won't discuss the
direct conversations between the
president and the vice president so
rather than asking you what the vice
president said in that meeting i'll ask
you more general question did the vice
president ever waver in his position
that he could not unilaterally decide
which electors to accept
the vice president never budged from the
position that i have described as his
first instinct which was
that it just made no sense from
everything that he knew and had studied
about our constitution that one person
would have that kind of authority did
the vice president ever waver in his
position that he could not delay
certification and send it back to the
states
no he did not
did dr eastman admit in front of the
president that his proposal would
violate the electoral account act
so during that meeting on the 4th
i think i
raised
the problem that
both of
mr eastman's proposals would violate
several provisions of the electoral
count act
mr eastman acknowledged that that was
the case um that
even what he viewed as the more
politically palatable option would
violate several provisions
but he thought that we could do so
because in his view the electoral can
act was unconstitutional
and when i raised concerns that that
position would likely lose in court his
view was that the court simply wouldn't
get involved they would invoke the
political question doctrine
and therefore we could have some comfort
proceeding with that path
mr wood but just to reiterate he told
you
maybe this was in a later conversation
but he told you at some point that if in
fact the issue ever got to the supreme
court
his theory would lose 9-0 correct
the next morning um
starting around 11 or 11 30 we met for
an hour and a half to two hours and in
that meeting
i've already described the text
structure history conversation but we
started walking through all of that and
i said you know john basically what you
have is
some text that may be a little bit
ambiguous but then
nothing else that would support it
including the fact that nobody would
ever want that to be the rule
wouldn't we lose nine to nothing in the
supreme court and again he
initially started well maybe you'd only
lose seven to two but ultimately
acknowledged that no we would lose nine
zero no judge would support his argument
after his meeting with the vice
president donald trump flew to georgia
for a rally in support of the republican
candidates in the united states senate
runoff
even though the vice president
was had been steadfast in resisting the
president's pressure
president trump continued to publicly
pressure vice president pence in his
georgia speech
rather than focusing exclusively on the
georgia senate runoff
trump turned his attention to mike pence
here's what the president said during
that rally in
georgia hence comes through for us i
have to tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
so the president had been told multiple
times that the vice president could not
affect the outcome of the election
but he nonetheless publicly pressured
mike pence to do exactly that by saying
quote if he doesn't come through
i won't like him as much
let's turn now to january 5th
mr wood
thank you
that morning meaning january 5th the
president issued a tweet expressly
stating that the vice president had the
power to reject electors
let's look at what the president wrote
quote the vice president has the power
to reject fraudulently chosen electors
mr jacob you've already told us about
your meeting with dr eastman and the
president on january 4th
and you briefly made reference to the
meeting you had with dr eastman the next
day january 5th can you tell us a little
bit more about the meeting with dr
eastman on january 5th for example
where was the meeting who was there
so at the
conclusion of the meeting on the 4th the
president had asked that um
that our office
meet with uh mr eastman the next day to
hear more
about the positions he had expressed at
that meeting and the vice president
indicated that um
offered me up as his counsel uh to
fulfill that duty so
we met in mark short's office in the
executive office building
across the way from the white house
dr eastman had a
court hearing by zoom that morning so
it didn't start first thing but rather
started around 11
and
that meeting went for about an hour and
a half two hours uh
chief of staff mark short was uh
at that meeting most of the time there
were a few times that he
left
and essentially it was an extended
discussion
what most surprised me about that
meeting was that when mr eastman came in
he
said
i'm here to request that you reject the
electors
so
on the fourth
that had been the path that he had
said i'm not recommending that you do
that
but on the fifth
he came in and um expressly requested
that and
i grabbed a notebook as i was heading
into the meeting
i didn't hear much new from him to
record but that was the first thing i
recorded
in my notes was request that the vp
reject
just to be clear
you're saying that dr eastman urged the
vice president to adopt the very same
approach
that dr eastman appeared to abandon in
the oval office meeting with the
president the day before is that correct
he had recommended against it the
evening before and then on the fifth
came in and i think it was probably his
first words after introductions and as
we sat down were i'm here to request
that you reject
the electors in the disputed states and
you referenced a moment ago some
handwritten notes which you've provided
to the select committee i'd now like to
show you
those notes
uh as you can see you wrote there at the
top the writing's a little bit faint in
the copy but you wrote
requesting vp reject does that
accurately reflect what dr eastman asked
of you
in your meeting on january 5th
yes
and what was your reaction when dr
eastman said on january 5th that he was
there to ask the vice president of the
united states to reject electors at the
joint session of congress
i was surprised
because i had viewed it as sort of one
of the key concessions that we had
secured the night before from mr eastman
that
um
that he was not recommending that we do
that so what did you say to him
well as i
indicated to some extent it simplified
my task because the
um
there are more procedural complexities
to the send it back to the state's point
of view and i actually had spent
most of my evening the night before
writing a memorandum to the vice
president explaining
um all of the specific provisions of the
electoral count act that plan would
violate
um so
instead
since he was uh
pushing
the
sort of robust unilateral power
theory
i've already walked the committee
through the discussions that we had we
again we
i started out with our points of
commonality uh or what i thought were
our points of commonality we're
conservatives we're small government
people we believe in originalism as the
means that by which we're going to
interpret this and so we walked through
the text we walked through the history
and that the committee has shown footage
of mr eastman on the stage on the 6th
claiming that jefferson supported his
position in a historical example of
jefferson in fact he conceded in that
meeting
jefferson did not at all support his
position that in the election
of 1800
there had been some small technical
defect with the certificate in georgia
it was absolutely undisputed that
jefferson had won georgia jefferson did
not assert that he had any authority to
reject electors he did not assert that
he had any authority to resolve any
issue
during the course of that
and so he acknowledged
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
deemed ourselves the winners of the
election
you would have an opposed house and
senate disagreeing with that
you would have state legislatures that
to that point i mean republican leaders
across those legislatures had put
together and put out statements and we
collected these for the vice president
as well
that the people had spoken in their
states and that they had no intention
of reversing the outcome of the election
we did receive some signed letters that
mr eastman forwarded us by
minorities of leaders in those states
but
no state had any legislative house that
indicated that had any interest in it so
you would have had
just an unprecedented
constitutional jump ball situation with
that standoff and as i expressed to him
that issue might well then have to be
decided in the streets
because if we can't work it out
politically
we've already seen
how charged up people are about this
election
and so
it would be a disastrous situation to be
in so i said i think the courts will
intervene i do not see
a commitment in the constitution of the
question whether the vice president has
that authority to some other actor to
resolve there there's arguments about
whether congress
and the vice president jointly
have a constitutional commitment to
generally decide electoral vote issues i
don't think that they have any authority
to object
or reject them i don't see it in the
12th amendment but nonetheless
and i concluded by saying
john
in light of everything that we've
discussed
can't you we just both agree that this
is a terrible idea
um
and he couldn't quite bring himself to
say yes to that but he very clearly
said well
yeah i see we're not going to be able to
persuade you to do this and that was how
the meeting concluded
you just described a terrifying scenario
sounds like there could have been chaos
under the eastman approach
and you even described it as it
potentially could be decided in the
streets
and you describe several concessions
that dr eastman made throughout that
discussion or even debate that you had
with him
at some point during that meeting on
january 5th
did dr eastman seem to
admit that both of the theories that he
had presented to the united states the
day before so
the theory that the vice president could
reject electors outright and declare
donald trump the winner
and his less aggressive theory
that
uh
the vice president could simply
send it back to the states at some point
in that conversation on the fifth did dr
eastman seem to admit that both of these
theories
suffered from similar legal flaws
so
i had
at least one possibly two other
conversations with dr eastman later that
day
in the earlier meeting we really were
focused because his request that he made
had been reject the electors outright
on why that theory was wrong and why we
certainly would not be doing
later that day
he pivoted back to
well
we hear you loud and clear you're not
going to reject
um but remember last night i said that
there was this more prudent course where
you could just send it back to the
states would you be willing to do that
and during the course of our discussion
about
his renewed request that we consider
that option
he acknowledged to me
he put it
both mr eastman and myself are graduates
of the university of chicago law school
and he said look as
graduates of that august institution you
and i will
mutually understand that the underlying
legal theory
of plenary
vice presidential authority is what you
have to have to get there because
this new theory as i was pointing out to
him
or the procedural theory
still violates several provisions of the
electoral count act as he acknowledged
and the only way that you could ever be
able to ignore several provisions of
statutory law as if it was pretty clear
that they were unconstitutional
and the only way they could be
unconstitutional
is if the vice president had the plenary
authorities that were formed to the
basis for the rejected votes as well
so
he acknowledged in those conversations
that the underlying legal theory was the
same
he just thought that the send it back to
the states option
would be more politically palatable and
he hoped more palatable to the vice
president for that reason and in fact
when dr eastman made this concession
during that meeting according to your
earlier deposition
dr eastman said
just between us university of chicago
chickens is that right
i don't think that the university of
chicago is going to start a chicago
chickens fundraiser
but yes that is the terminology that he
used he said you know just between us
chicago chickens we will understand
um as as lawyers who have studied the
constitution that the
underlying basis really is the same
i reserve the remainder of my time thank
you mr wood
mr jacob the president and the vice
president meet again on that same topic
the next day
january 5th correct
there
so after my
extended meeting
with mr eastman that morning
during that time the vice president had
been back at his residence
working on his statement to the nation
that we released the next day
um he
got down to the white house
some point between one o'clock and two
o'clock as
my meeting
uh with mr eastman was wrapping up
and when we
mark short and i went over to meet with
the vice president and
um actually we thought maybe we had good
news we felt like we had sort of
defeated uh mr eastman that he was sort
of acknowledging that there was no there
there
but the vice president was then um asked
down to the oval office
and he went down to the oval office um
while mark and i stayed back in the vice
president's office you weren't in that
meeting
i was not
in the book peril journalists bob
woodward and robert costa write that the
president said quote
if these people say you have the power
wouldn't you want to
the vice president says quote i wouldn't
want any one person to have that
authority
the president responds
but wouldn't it almost be cool to have
that power
vice president is reported to have said
no look i've read this and i don't see a
way to do it we've exhausted every
option i've done everything i could and
then some to find a way around this it's
simply not possible my interpretation is
no
to which the president says no no no
you don't understand mike you can do
this
i don't want to be your friend anymore
if you don't do this
we asked mark short about this during
his deposition
the understanding that i would have
um
in other conversations
with the vice president
he articulated to me
that
no he wouldn't want that power bestowed
upon any one person
mr jacob did you mr short and the vice
president have a call later that day
again with the president and dr eastman
so yes we did
and what did dr eastman request on that
call
on that phone call which
i believe was around five o'clock that
afternoon
um
mr eastman
stated that he had heard us loud and
clear that morning we were not going to
be rejecting electors
but
would we be open to considering the
other course that we had discussed on
the 4th which would be to
suspend the joint session
and request that state legislatures
re-examine
certification of the electoral votes
that same day january 5th the new york
times ran a story about the disagreement
between the president and the vice
president about whether the vice
president could determine the outcome of
the election
even though the new york times story was
indisputably correct
donald trump denied it
trump issued a statement claiming that
the vice president had agreed that he
could determine the outcome of the
election despite the fact that the vice
president had consistently rejected that
position
let's look at what the president said in
his statement
quote the new york times report
regarding comments vice president pence
supposedly made to me today is fake news
he never said that
the vice president and i are in total
agreement that the vice president has
the power to act
mr jacob how did the vice president's
team react to the statement from the
president that the vice president could
take an active role in determining the
winner of the presidential election
um so
we were shocked and disappointed
because whoever had written and put that
statement out it was categorically
untrue
vice president's chief of staff mark
short had an angry phone call with trump
campaign senior advisor jason miller
about this statement
here's what mr short and mr miller told
the committee about that call
okay tell me about the conversation you
had with jason it was brief i
was um
irritated
and expressed uh displeasure that uh
statement could have gone out that
misrepresented the vice president's
viewpoint without consultation
the statement says the vice president
and i are in total agreement that the
vice president has the power to act is
that incorrect
i think the record shows that that's
incorrect yeah i mean we've been through
many documents that clarify that this is
not where the vice president was right
so essentially
the president's sending out a boldly
false statement about being in alignment
purported alignment with the vice
president despite all of the predicate
that you indicated had gone before about
their respective positions is that
effectively what happened i interpret
the statement as false i'll let you
figure out who sent it out
when mark short contacted you
he
he was upset is that what she said
he clearly was not pleased
tell us what he said
what's the process for putting out a
statement
for a meeting where only two people were
in the room
did he ask you to retract the statement
no he just i think it went right to
what's the process for putting out a
statement
for a meeting when only two people were
in the room
and he clearly disagreed with the
substance though right because he said
that he said the vice president doesn't
agree with this
try to think what exactly he said i mean
the the tone
i was very clearly
that uh
uh he used some language to
uh strongly infer that the vice
president disagreed with that take but i
don't remember what that language was
did he dictate this statement
we
uh he dictated uh
he dictated most of it i mean typically
on these um
typically on these i might have a couple
of wording suggestions uh or
um maybe i
you know have a a sentence or a rough
framework or something of that uh but i
i know
with uh specificity on this one that
it was me and him on the phone
talking through it
and
ultimately the way this came out
was the way that he wanted to
the dispute between the president and
the vice president had grown to the
point where the vice president's chief
of staff mark short was concerned that
the president could in mr short's words
lash out at the vice president on
january 6th
in fact mr short was so concerned about
it that he talked with the head of the
vice president's secret service detail
on january 5th
here's mr short
concern was for the vice president's
security and so i wanted to make sure
the head of the vice president secret
service
was aware that
that likely
as these disagreements became more
public that the president would
lash out in some way
after the recess we will hear that mark
short's concerns were justified
the vice president was in danger
mr chairman i reserve
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today the chair declares the
committee in recess for a period of
approximately 10 minutes
so as the committee goes to a break we
will bring in a few for
for some commentary here uh you see the
committee leaving
um we have a few people to to hear from
a lot to digest here i want to bring in
david bender and my co-host gabe sanchez
uh david and gabe um
what uh what was your thoughts for some
of the testimony here
uh
i'm sorry we're we're buffering here i'm
live yeah you know
um
well
listen we we've
read judge luke's statement
i wish he had
uh it is a very powerful statement i
think that uh
it's unfortunate
uh well let me ask you both just a quick
question if you haven't looked it up how
old do you think ludicr is
you know i'm not i'm not really sure um
i don't like 72 yeah there you go
he just turned 68 three days ago
uh i'm
i'm a little concerned because it's
closing in on on where i'm gonna be
and i hope i speak a little more clearly
than that here's here's the problem
i think he's very uncomfortable doing
this in public this is not what he likes
to do
i he's made that clear he's given no
interviews i saw an interview
during this i wanted to see if he had
spoken publicly before and he did the
bill crystal
uh
an old friend
he talked as we're talking now he talked
conversationally he was able to speak
clearly this is something he
rather like mueller he didn't want to do
and you can see it you can feel it
so he's speaking very precisely so he's
choosing his words as carefully as
possible so let's let's forget about
style and go to substance the substance
of what he said was profoundly important
that this is a constitutional crisis
and
he didn't mince words about that he took
a long time getting there but if i
encourage everyone
to read his statement i'm just going to
read the first
line of it
a state was driven through the heart of
america democracy on january 6 2021 and
our democracy today is on knife edge
i wish he'd said that right
we just did
and for everyone listening here
please take read this statement
because what he can do brilliantly
is express
the danger to the republic
that this uh
this action this pressure on vice
president pence specifically took
to put the country in danger of losing
our constitutional liberty and he says
that flat out
here
what i do think was important about what
we saw
was that they're laying out the case and
particularly through the clips
they're laying out the case of
uh step by step
how
trump ignored and we we saw it just
right before the break we saw him lying
it couldn't be more clear
uh what's the process for
issuing a statement when only two people
are in the room
right the two people in the room were
trump and pence
trump out and
very specifically
uh it was made clear by chase and miller
of all people
that
that that in fact this was dictated to
him by trump yep the vice president and
i are in complete agreement that he has
the power
that is a flat out lie
designed to ratchet up the pressure on
mike pence right right well i want to
bring in texas paul and uh the trump
nba killer
jessica denson because i like their take
before the committee comes back but i
want to go to texas paul first and the
reason why is because i want your take
real quick on
what the judge said about lying in the
street before he let because it sounded
like it sounded like texas paul type
language
when he talked about lying in the street
before he let his democracy go down what
did you think of that moment paul
i'm sorry
every time i don't he is a brilliant man
but i
felt like i was stuck in the dmv at zoo
in the movie zootopia the whole time i
just
but but you know he meant
every word
he
meant every word of that he said i will
die before i let this happen right and
this is a republican folks i mean this
is not a democrat right he
was trying his level best to stress just
how serious this was how serious it is
now
we really need to pay attention to what
he said i know it's easy to get lost in
in
the theater of it yeah he talks love but
listen to the words the man says that's
right i would be willing to lay in the
street and die
before i let this happen because it's
the end
of our country
that's a great point so jessica uh
follow up on that because you talk a lot
about this um because of
how you fought back against the trump
team but uh your old boss d bannon also
made an appearance in one of the clips
there um so tell us about you know the
fight for democracy
and
you know
the mindset of this trump team because
it seemed like they were grasping at any
straw that they possibly could give and
it seems like this is a theme
throughout the trump presidency on
almost anything you know they would they
would come out and be discovered there's
a lie and they would reverse engineer if
that's a good word you know all of this
so it seemed like they were almost
reverse engineering and finding any
straw that they could find even all the
way back to something that thomas
jefferson actually did not do as they
stated here in the hearing so what's
your take on on the testimony so far
well that's what a malignant narcissist
always does is surround themselves with
sycophants who will tell them what they
want to hear constantly right was this
was completely predictable from the
beginning of trump's testimony or
trump's testimony trump's presidency but
chiming in on what david and
paul said
i couldn't agree more the judge speaks
slowly but i actually found him to be
very deliberative i appreciated the time
he was taking i hadn't heard him speak
publicly before so i didn't know that he
doesn't normally speak this way but if
you listen to what he said in the open
he said the rule of law is the
foundational truth of this country he
said it's the foundational truth it's a
symbol and it is profound the rule of
law now i want to leave you with one
thing if you noticed that conversation
from greg jacob where he was talking
about mike pence saying when i go to
heaven see about that right when i go to
heaven i want to tell the founders that
um the constitution was divinely
inspired but maybe they made a mistake
with the 12th amendment or the electoral
count after the 12th amendment
specifically
but you know what's divinely inspired
the criminal laws that we have in the
federal statute
the code that makes it a crime to
conspire to defraud the united states
that is divinely inspired and so i am
inspired that we have the ammunition to
hold these people and donald trump
himself who is responsible for violating
that foundational truth that holds us up
as a democracy
in our hands to utilize
and thank you jessica and as we uh sit
here and
watch the hearing room um david what do
you expect us to see in here in the
second half after the break what do you
think we're gonna have uh as far as
content here are we gonna have a lot of
clips and video testimony are we gonna
hear
more from witnesses which
i i know that these are the only two
witnesses that they have my guess is
that they are
going to do their very best because i
think it's run a little longer than they
thought
uh to not
focus on judge ludwig further i think
they have plenty of clips to go to
but
just to the point
of how powerful judge ludwig's words are
much better on the page than
having a way through them war on
democracy
instigated by the former president and
his political party allies on january 6
was the natural and foreseeable
culmination of the war for america
it was the final fateful day for the
execution of a well-developed plan
by the former president to overturn the
2020 presidential election at any cost
so that he could cling to the power that
the american people had decided to
confer upon his successor the next
president
uh knowing full well that he lost the
2020 presidential election the former
president and his allies and supporters
falsely claimed and proclaimed the
nation that he had won the election and
then he and they set about to overturn
the election that he and they knew the
former president had lost
the treacherous plan was no less
ambitious than to steal america's
democracy
now that that's judge ludwig
that's how
completely to the point
his sentiments about this are
and i hope that we take that away from
this today but more to the point i hope
we keep pumping that out
i would hope to your question i would
hope that the committee reads some of
that into the record not just puts it in
the record but reads it and gets him to
simply nod his head in agreement
that would be great
right well and and uh to the point that
the judge
did take a while to say some of the
statements that he said
um
to the general counsel the former
council of mike pence he was very snappy
in some of his responses um he was very
quick to say yes no bam bam bam and be
very precise almost like a scalpel uh
jessica what did you make of that
testimony when he was slicing and dicing
there yeah you know what what i was
actually thinking about when you were
talking about that is how they brought
out that eastman
had one opinion about the illegality of
this coup attempt this this plan to
pressure mike pence on january 5th
and then his mind changed on january 6th
what do we all know is the one factor
that changed his position
donald j trump donald trump was calling
the shots yup yup i believe so texas
paul what was what was your take because
i actually tweeted out something like
eastman didn't even believe his own big
pile of steamy [ __ ] um you know he he
didn't even believe this because
he was he was even admitting that yes we
would lose nine to nothing right like he
had moved so far from maybe we'd get
three votes that there's no way and
there's no chance in hell we'd win so
what was your take on that testimony
where he's saying john eastman didn't
even believe this stuff
well you know i was actually sitting
there thinking when i was listening to
it about something that jessica said
earlier i think david you mentioned this
also about merrick garland he is
not
he's like the terminator
there's not any emotion there once the
crime's there
i i you could shoot the guy with a 12
gauge he's still going to crawl after
you and put your ass in jail and
everything we've heard so far
has been the crime
i mean we have heard enough you don't
have to succeed
for you to have committed this crime
i mean failing doesn't mean that they
didn't attempt it and we heard today
they
absolutely attempted it yep i mean
they're gonna go it's undeniable i don't
mean to cut you off there paul we're
gonna get back to the hearings uh here
uh if you guys want to stick around
after we'd love to hear some more
commentary from you guys so stick around
after
we go back to the hearing
committee will be in order
gentleman from california mr aguilar is
recognized
i'd now like to turn to the events of
january 6 2021
which turned out to be a fateful day in
our nation's
history despite the fact that the vice
president consistently told the
president that he did not have and would
not want the power to decide the outcome
of the presidential election
donald trump continued to pressure the
vice president both publicly
and privately
as you will hear
things reached a boiling point on
january 6th
and the consequences were disastrous
in the middle of the night
on january 5th into the morning of the
6th around 1am
president trump tweeted at
the vice president
meaning that the comments in response to
the president's tweet
would also show up
on the vice president's twitter feed
the tweet stated that
the vice president could quote come
through for us
and
send it back to the states
then around 8 am on january 6 president
trump again tweeted
this time
to say that the vice president
could send it back to the states and
we win
and that this is the time
for extreme courage
mr short told us during his deposition
that the vice president
started a meeting on january 6th
in prayer
here is what mr short said
you arrived at the vice president's
residence um
as would often be the case i recall that
knowing it would be an important day
we gathered in prayer and
often that would be something the staff
member would would lead so it would have
just been at that time i believe
the vice president myself
greg and chris
and
we would have just asked for
guidance and wisdom knowing that the day
was going to be a challenging one
mr jacob did you go to the vice
president's residences on the morning of
january 6th
yes
who else was with you
um mark short
devin o'malley our communications
director and chris hodgson our
legislative affairs director
and did the vice president have a call
with the president that morning
he did
were you with the vice president during
the call
so we had been
um
putting the
the vice president had finalized his
statement overnight we were in the
process of proofing it so that we could
get that out
um and
we were told that a call had come in
from the president
the vice president stepped out of the
room to take that call and no staff went
with him
the president had several family members
with him
in the oval
that morning for that call
i'd like to show you what they and
others told the select committee about
that call
along with never before seen photographs
of the president on that call from the
national archives
when i got in
uh
somebody called me and said that
the family and others were in the oval
and do i want to come up
so i i went upstairs uh and who do you
recall being in the oval office
uh don jr eric laura
kimberly i believe meadows was there
at some point ivanka
came in
it wasn't as specific
formal discussion it was
very sort of loose and casual so then
you said at some point there's
a telephone conversation between the
president and the vice president is that
correct yes
when i entered the office the second
time
he was
on the telephone with who i later found
out to be was the the vice president
could you hear the vice president or
only hear the president's end i only
heard the president said but at some
point it started off
as a calmer tone and everything and then
became heated the conversation was was
pretty heated
i think until it became
somewhat you know louder tone
i don't think anyone's paying attention
to it initially
did you hear any part of the phone call
even if just this the end that the
president was speaking from i did yes
all right and what'd you hear
so as i was dropping off the note um
my memory i remember hearing the word
wimp either he called him a wimp i don't
remember if he said you are a wimp
you'll be a whim wimp is the word i
remember it's also been reported that
the president said to the vice president
that something to the effect of you
don't have the courage to make a hard
decision
worse i don't remember exactly either
but something like that yeah
being
like being you're not tough enough to
make the call it was a different tone
than i'd heard him take um with the vice
president before did miss trump share
with you any more details about what had
happened or any details about what had
happened in the oval office that morning
that her dad
had just had an upsetting conversation
with the vice president do you recall
anything about her demeanor either
during the meeting or when you
encountered her in dance cabino's office
i don't remember specifically i mean i
think she was
uncomfortable over the fact that there
was obviously that type of interaction
between the two of them something to the
effect this is
the wording's wrong
i made the wrong decision four or five
years ago and the the word that she
relayed to that the president called the
vice president i apologize for being
impolite but do you remember what she
said her father called him
the p word
mr jacob how would you describe
the demeanor of the vice president
following the call following that call
with the president
when he came back into the room i'd say
that he was
steely
determined
grim
of course the most dangerous part of
what donald trump did on january 6th
was
what he did
himself
as we'll be discussed in detail in a
future hearing our investigation found
that early drafts of the january 6
ellipse speech prepared for the
president included no mention of the
vice president
but the president revised it to include
criticism of the vice president and then
further ad-libbed
here is what the president said on
january 6th after his call with vice
president pence
i hope mike is going to do the right
thing i hope so i hope so
because if mike pence does the right
thing
we win the election all vice president
pence has to do is send it back to the
states to recertify
and we become president and you are the
happiest people
[Applause]
and i actually
i just spoke to mike i said mike that
doesn't take courage what takes courage
is to do nothing
that takes courage and then we're stuck
with a president who lost the election
by a lot and we have to live with that
for four more years we're just not going
to let that happen and mike pence is
going to have to come through for us and
if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
and
they want to re-certify their votes
they want to re-certify but the only way
that can happen is if mike pence agrees
to send it back
so i hope mike has the courage to do
what he has to do
and i hope he doesn't listen to the
rhinos and the stupid people that he's
listening to
of course we all know what happened next
the president's words had an effect
president trump's supporters became
angry
when the vice president issued his
public letter the crowd at the capitol
erupted in anger
the rioters who had erected makeshift
gallows began chanting hang mike pence
testimony in our investigation has made
clear
what the target of the rioters ire was
vice president mike pence
the rioters breached the capitol
at 2 13 pm
hey guys
now let's take a look at what was going
on at the white house at this time
we received testimony that the
president's chief of staff mark meadows
was notified of the violence at the
capitol
by 2 pm and likely earlier
the testimony further establishes that
mr meadows quickly informed the
president and that he did so before
the president issued his 2 24 pm tweet
criticizing vice president pence
for not having quote
courage to do what needed to be done
here is what the president wrote in his
2 24 pm tweet
while the violence at the capitol was
going on
and here's what the rioters thought
nothing but a traitor and he deserves to
burn with the rest of them so that's why
it's all escalated after pence what what
happened to pence
pence didn't do what we wanted pence
voted against trump okay and that's when
all this started yep that's when we
marched on the capitol we've been shot
at with rubber bullets tear death
we've just heard that
it's
[Applause]
[Music]
has betrayed the united states of
america
and he has betrayed the people of the
united states
it's real simple
hence betrayed us
which apparently everybody knew he was
going to
and the president mentioned it
like five times when he talked
you can go back and watch the
president's video
this is our capital just be respectful
to him
there's four million people coming in so
[Applause]
it's only a matter of time justice is
coming
although the president's chief of staff
mark meadows has refused to testify
before this committee mr meadows aide
ben williamson and white house deputy
press secretary sarah matthews testified
that mr meadows went to the dining room
near the oval office to tell the
president about the violence at the
capitol before the president's 2 24 pm
tweet
in future hearings you'll hear more
about exactly what was happening in the
white house at that time
but here is what some white house staff
told the select committee
do you know where he went
uh yes i followed him down the hallway
uh and i followed him
into the outer oval corridor
which is the hallway between uh the oval
office
hallway
and the outer oval section of the oval
office
i followed him into that little corridor
hallway
um i saw him walk into outer oval
i maybe took a step into outer oval and
then left
and i don't know where he went outside
of that but it looked like he was headed
in the direction of the oval office
you know we had all
talked about at that point about how it
was um bad and the um you know situation
was getting out of hand
and um
i know ben williamson and i were uh
conferring and uh we thought that the
president needed to tweet something and
tweet something immediately
and um i think when kaylee gave us that
order of don't say anything to the media
i
told her that i thought the president
needed to tweet something
and um
then
i remember um
then i remember getting um a
notification on my phone and i was
sitting in a room with um roma and ben
and
we all got a notification so
we knew it was a tweet from the
president
and we looked down
and it was
a tweet about mike pence
uh i believe i had sent him a text
uh saying that we may want to put out
some sort of statement
uh because the situation was
was getting a little hairy over at the
capitol
um and then it was common for after i
would text him
uh i would just go down and
see him in person you went down to speak
with mark meadows after this what was
that conversation
uh very brief i went down and told him
the same thing i have in the text that i
can recall
um
and i i don't remember anything that was
said
between us other than i told him that
and to my recollection he immediately
got up and left his office
our investigation found that immediately
after the president's 2 24 pm tweet the
crowds both outside the capitol and
inside the capitol surged
the crowds inside the capitol were able
to overwhelm the law enforcement
presence and the vice president was
quickly evacuated from his ceremonial
senate office to a secure location
within the capitol complex
by 2 24 pm the secret service had moved
vice president pence from the senate
chamber to his office across the hall
the noise from the rioters became
audible at which point we recognized
that maybe they had gotten into the
building then
president trump tweeted
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution
giving states a chance to certify a
corrected set of facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify
usa demands the truth
it was clear that it was escalating and
escalating quickly
[Applause]
so then when
that tweet the mike pence tweet um was
sent out um i remember us saying that
that was the last thing that needed to
be tweeted at that moment
the situation was already bad and so it
felt like he was pouring gasoline on the
fire by tweeting that
30 seconds later rioters already inside
the capitol
opened the east rotunda door
just down the hall
and just 30 seconds after that
rioters breached the crypt
one floor below the vice president the
secret service couldn't control the
situation and do their job of keeping
him safe at 2 26 p.m
secret service rushed vice president
pence down the stairs i think they've
been trying to figure out whether they
had a clear route
to get us to wherever it was wanted to
move this too we moved pretty quickly
downstairs and through various hallways
and tunnels to the secure location upon
arriving there there was further
discussion as to whether or not we were
going to leave the capital complex or
stay where we were
vice president pence and his team
ultimately were led to a secure location
where they stayed for the next four and
a half hours
barely missing rioters a few feet away
approximately 40 feet
that's all there was
40 feet between the vice president and
the mob
mr jacob you were there
sing that for the first time
does it surprise you to see how close
the mob was to the evacuation route that
you took
the 40 feet is the distance from me to
you roughly
i could hear the den of the rioters in
the building while we moved but i don't
think i was aware that they were as
close as that
make no mistake about the fact that the
vice president's life was in danger
a recent court filing by the department
of justice explains that a confidential
informant from the proud boys told the
fbi the proud boys
would have killed mike pence if given a
chance
this witness
whom the fbi affidavit refers to as w1
stated that other members of the group
talked about things they did that day
and they said that anyone they got their
hands on they would have killed
including nancy pelosi
w1 further stated that members of the
proud boys said
that they would have killed mike pence
if given a chance
we understand that congressional leaders
and others were evacuated from the
capitol complex during the attack
we'd like to show you what happened
after the vice president was evacuated
from the senate
select committee has obtained
never-before-seen photos from the
national archives that show vice
president pence sheltering in a secure
underground location as rioters
overwhelmed the capital
at 4 19 pm
vice president pence is seen looking at
a tweet the president had just sent
a tweet asking the rioters to leave the
capitol
after four and a half hours spent on
working to restore order the vice
president returned to the senate floor
to continue the certification of
electors
so vice president pence was a focus of
the violent attack
mr jacob did the vice president leave
the capitol complex during the attack
did not
can you please explain why the vice
president refused to leave the capitol
complex
when we got down to the secure location
secret service directed us to get into
the cars
um which i did um and then i noticed
that the vice president had not so i got
out of the car that i had gotten and
gotten into
um and i understood that the vice
president had refused to get into
the car um the
head of his secret service detail tim
had said
i assure you we're not going to drive
out of the building without your
permission and the vice president had
said something to the effect of
tim i know you i trust you but you're
not the one behind the wheel and the
vice president did not want to take any
chance
that
um the world would see the vice
president of the united states fleeing
the united states capital he was
determined
that we would complete the work that we
had um set out to do that day that it
was his constitutional duty to see
through
and the the
rioters who had breached the capital
would not have the satisfaction of uh
disrupting
the proceedings beyond the day on which
they were supposed to be completed
let me see if i understand this right
you were told to get in the cars
and how many of the vice president's
staff got into cars while he did not
most of us
during our investigation we received
testimony that while the vice president
was in a secure location within the
capitol complex he continued the
business of government
we understand that the vice president
reached out to congressional leaders
like the acting secretary of defense and
others to check on their safety and to
address the growing crisis
in addition the vice president's chief
of staff mark short made several calls
to senior government officials
here's mr short's testimony regarding
his call with representative kevin
mccarthy
he indicated that uh
he had had some conversation i don't
recall whether it was with the president
or somebody at the white house but i
think he he expressed frustration that
uh um not taken the circumstance as
seriously as they showed that moment so
mr mccarthy indicated he'd been in touch
with someone at the white house and he
conveyed to you that they weren't taking
this as seriously as they should
if they have to answer yes or no yes
okay
while the vice president made several
calls to check on the safety of others
it was his own life that was in great
danger
mr jacob did donald trump ever call the
vice president to check on his safety
he did not
mr jacob how did vice president pence
and mrs pence react to that
with frustration
mr jacob immediately before you and the
vice president were evacuated to a
secure location within the capitol
you hit send on an email to john eastman
explaining why his legal theory
about the vice president's role was
wrong
you ended your email
by stating that quote
thanks to your [ __ ] we are now under
siege
we'll take a look at that email
and dr eastman replied
and this is hard to believe but his
reply back to you was
the siege
is because you
and your boss presumably referring to
the vice president in the united states
did not do what was necessary to allow
this to be aired in a public way so the
american people can see for themselves
what happened
mr jacob later that day you wrote again
to dr eastman let's show that email on
the screen
in that email you wrote and i quote did
you advise the president that in your
professional judgment the vice president
does not have the power to decide things
unilaterally
and you ended that email saying it does
not appear that the president ever got
the memo
dr eastman then replied
he's been so advised
and he ends his email with
quote but you know him
once he gets something in his head
it's hard to get him to change course
close quote
mr jacob when dr eastman wrote once he
gets something in his head it's hard to
get him to change course did you
understand the he in that email
to refer to the president of the united
states
i
did
and mr jacob did you hear from dr
eastman further
after the riot had been quelled and if
so
what did he ask
late that evening
after the joint session had been
reconvened
the vice president had given
a statement to the nation saying that
violence was not going to win freedom
wins
and that the people were going to get
back to doing their work
um
later that evening
mr eastman emailed me
to point out that in his view the vice
president's speech
to the nation um violated the electoral
count act
that the electoral count act had been
violated because the debate on arizona
had not been completed in two hours
of course it couldn't be since there was
an intervening riot of several hours
and the speeches that the majority and
minority leaders had been allowed to
make also violated the electoral count
act because they hadn't been
counted against the debate time
and then he implored me now that we have
established that the electoral count act
um isn't so sacrosanct as
you have made it out to be
i implore you one last time can the vice
president please do what we've been
asking him to do these last two days
suspend the joint session send it back
to the states
and we'll show you the text of that
email which dr eastman wrote at 11 44
p.m
on january 6th so after the attack on
the capitol and after law enforcement
had secured the capital
he still wrote as you described quote so
now that the precedent has been set that
the electoral count act is not quite so
sacrosanct as was previously claimed
i implore you to consider
one more relatively minor violation and
adjourn for 10 days to allow the
legislatures to finish their
investigations
even after the attack on the capital
been quell dr eastman requested
in writing no less
that the vice president violate the law
by delaying the certification and
sending the question back to the states
is that correct mr jacob
it is
did you eventually share dr eastman's
proposal with vice president pence
uh
not right at that time because the vice
president was completing uh the work um
that it was his duty to do
but a day or two later back at the white
house i did show him
that final email from mr eastman and
what was vice president pence's reaction
when you showed him the email where dr
eastman
after the attack on the capitol still
asked that the vice president delay
certification and send it back to the
states
he said
that's rubber room stuff
i'm sorry
he said it's rubber room stuff
yes congressman what did you interpret
that to mean
i understood it to mean that
after having seen play out
um
what happens when you
convince people that there is a decision
to be made in the capital legitimately
about who is to be the president and the
consequences of that he was still
pushing us to do
what
he had been asking us to do for the
previous two days
that that was
certifiably crazy
we know that the vice president did not
do what dr eastman requested because he
presided over the completion of the
counting of electoral votes late in that
evening
number of electors appointed to vote for
president of the united states is 538.
within that whole number a majority is
270.
the votes for president of the united
states are as follows
joseph r biden jr
of the state of delaware has received
306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
the whole number of electors appointed
to vote for vice president of the united
states is 538
within that whole number a majority is
270.
the votes for vice president of the
united states are as follows
kamala d harris of the state of
california
has received 306 votes
michael r pence of the state of indiana
has received 232 votes
the announcement of the state of the
vote
by the president of the senate
shall be deemed a sufficient declaration
of the persons elected president and
vice president of the united states
each for the term beginning on the 20th
day of january
2021 and shall be entered together with
the list of the votes on the journals of
the senate and the house of
representatives
mr jacob we heard earlier that you and
the vice president and the team started
january 6 with a prayer
you faced a lot of danger that day
and this is a personal question
but how did your faith guide you on
january 6th
um
my faith really sustained me through it
[Music]
i down in the secure location
pulled out my bible
read through it
and i just
took great comfort um
daniel 6 uh was where i went and um
in daniel 6
daniel has become the
second in command of babylon a pagan
nation but he
completely faithfully serves
he refuses an order from the king
that he cannot follow
and he does his duty
in consistent with his oath to god and
i felt that that's what had played out
that day
it spoke to you
yes
at the end of the day mark short sent
the vice president a text message with
the bible verse here's what he told the
select committee
at
3 50 in the morning when we finally
adjourned and
headed our own ways
i remember you know texting the vice
president a a passage from second
timothy chapter four verse seven
about um i fought the good fight i
finished the race i've kept the faith
he started his day with the prayer
and ended his day with a bible verse
i've
fought the good fight i finished the
race i've kept the faith
white house attorney
eric hershman testified that the next
day january 7th he received a call from
dr eastman here is mr hershman's account
of that call
the day after
eastman
i don't remember why he called me and he
or he texted me or called me
want to talk with me and he said he
couldn't reach others
and he started to
asked me about
something dealing with georgia and
preserving something potentially for
appeal
uh
and
i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
right
i said i
could i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth for now on
orderly transition
and that screamer said i don't want to
hear any other fn words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
and actually
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're going to need it
then i hung up on them
in fact just a few days later dr eastman
emailed rudy giuliani and requested that
he be included on a list of potential
recipients of a presidential pardon
dr eastman's email stated quote
i've decided that i should be on the
pardon list if that is still in the
works
dr eastman did not receive his
presidential pardon
so let's see what dr eastman did
as a result when he was deposed by this
committee
i assert my fifth amendment right
against being compelled to be a witness
against myself did the trump legal team
ask you to prepare a memorandum
regarding the vice president's role in
the accounting of electoral votes at the
joint session of congress on january 6
2022.
dr eastman did you advise the president
of the united states that the vice
president could reject electors from
seven states and declare that the
president had been realized
dr eastman the first sentence of the
memo
starts off by saying seven states have
transmitted dual slate's electors to the
president of the senate
is that statement in this memo true
fifth
president trump authorized you to
discuss publicly your january 4th 2021
conversation with them
uh
so is it your position that you can
discuss in the media direct
conversations you had with the president
of the united states but you will not
discuss those same conversations with
this committee
dr eastman plead the fifth
a hundred times
finally let's hear from a federal court
judge the only one to date who is opined
on whether the president was involved in
criminal activity
page 36 of judge carter's ruling says
quote based on the evidence the court
finds it more likely than not that the
president president trump
corruptly attempted to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021
page 40 of the ruling says
based on the evidence the court finds
that it is more likely than not that
president trump and dr eastman
dishonestly conspired to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021
in page 44
dr eastman and president trump launched
a campaign to overturn a democratic
election in action unprecedented in
american history
their campaign was not confined to the
ivory tower
it was a coup in search of a legal
theory
mr jacob what would have happened to our
democracy if vice president pence had
gone along with this plan and certified
donald trump as the winner of the 2020
election
so there would have been
short term and long-term effects
the short-term i've previously described
a constitutional jump ball situation
political chaos in washington
lawsuits
um and who knows what's happening in the
streets and you would have had the vice
president of the united states having
declared
that the outcomes of these state
elections were incorrect
so for all of those reasons
there would have been significant
short-term consequences
but in the long term
um
we would have established a situation
where a vice president
would have asserted that one person
could have the authority to determine
the outcome of an election which is
antithetical to everything in our
democracy
it's antithetical to the rule of law
and so
it would have been
um uh
significant impacts both in the short
and the long term
judge ludwig in the statement you
released earlier today you wrote that
the efforts by president trump to
overturn the 2020 election were quote
the most reckless insidious and
calamitous failures in both legal and
political judgment in american history
what did you mean by that
exactly what i said congressman
thank you judge
thank you mr jacob mr chairman i yield
back
gentlemen i'm sorry
i'm sorry mr chairman i want that back
mr chairman this was an informative
hearing a powerful hearing
i'm grateful for your leadership and the
leadership of the distinguished vice
chair
donald trump knew he lost the 2020
election
but he could not bring himself to
participate in the peaceful transfer of
power
so he latched on to a scheme that once
again he knew was illegal
and when the vice president refused to
go along with it
he unleashed a violent mob against him
when we began i asked how we got to this
place
and i think the answer to that question
starts with the fact that people in
positions of power
put their political party before their
country
cannot be allowed to continue
i'll yield back now mr chairman thank
you very much without objection the
chair recognizes the gentlewoman from
wyoming ms cheney for a closing
statement
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you to my colleague representative
aguilar and thank you very much to our
witnesses today mr jacob and judge
ludwig thank you for for being here with
us
um we have seen so far in in our
hearings that president trump knew that
his claims of a stolen election were
false you have seen that i knew that
mike pence could not legally refuse to
count electoral votes
and you have seen what might what
president trump did to pressure mike
pence into taking illegal action
over the course of our next hearings you
will see information about president
trump's efforts
john eastman efforts the trump legal
team's efforts to apply pressure to
republican state legislatures state
officials and
others judge carter has recently written
quote dr eastman's actions in these few
weeks indicate that his and president
trump's pressure campaign
to stop the electoral count
did not end with vice president pence it
targeted every tier of federal and state
elected officials
we will examine all of those threats
and we will examine the trump team's
determination to transmit materially
false electoral slates from multiple
states to officials of the executive and
legislative branches of our government
we will examine the pressures put on
state legislatures to convene to reverse
lawful election results
an honorable man
receiving the information and advice
that mr trump received from his campaign
experts and his staff
a man who loved his country more than
himself
would have conceded this election
indeed we know that a number of
president trump's closest aides urged
him to do so
this committee will address all of these
issues in greater detail in the coming
weeks mr chairman i yield back
young lady yields back
judge ludic
and mr jacob
our nation holds your great debt
for your knowledge integrity
and your loyalty to our constitution
you and vice president pence
are exactly the people our nation needed
at a critical time
you had the courage to do what was right
in the weeks leading up to january 6th
many people failed this test
when they had to choose between their
oath to the country or the demands of
donald trump
but there were others who like you stood
tall
in the face of intimidation
and put our democracy first
they include the judges who rejected the
bogus claims of election fraud
the senior justice department officials
who stood up to donald trump
and the state officials whom we will
hear from at our next hearing we're
deeply grateful to your courage and
devotion to our country
there are some who think the danger has
passed
that even though there were violence and
a corrupt attempt to overturn the
presidential election
the system worked
i look at it another way
our system nearly failed and our
democratic foundation destroyed
but for people like you
judge ludic
i want to give you an opportunity to
share your thoughts
on the ongoing threat
you've written the clear and present
danger to our democracy
now is that former president donald
trump and other political allies
appear prepared
to seize the presidency in 2024 if mr
trump
are one of his anointed candidates is
not elected by the american people
what do you mean by this
mr chairman
i'm honored beyond words
by your words
i was honored on january 6
2021
then
also honored beyond words
to have been able
to come to the aid
of vice president mike
pence
i prayed that day
just like
the vice president prayed that day
i believe we may have
prayed
the same prayer to the same god
i prayed
that same prayer
with my wife this morning before i came
into these hearings
i have written
as you said
chairman thompson
that
today
almost two years after
that fateful day
in january 2021
that still
donald trump
and his
allies and supporters
are a clear and present danger
to american democracy
that's not because
of what happened on january 6th
it's because to this very day
the former president
his allies and supporters
pledge
that in
the presidential
election of 2024
if
the former president
or
his anointed
successor as the republican party
presidential candidate
were to
lose
that election
that they would
attempt to overturn that 2024 election
in the same way that they
attempted to overturn
the 2020 election
but succeed
in 2024 where they failed
in 2020.
i don't
speak those words
lightly
i would have never
spoken
those words ever in my life
except that
that's what
the former president and his allies
are telling us
as i said in that new york times op-ed
wherein i was speaking
about the electoral count act of 1887
the former president and his allies
are
executing that blueprint
for 2024
in open
and plain view
of the american public
i repeat
i would have never uttered one single
one of those words
unless the former president and his
allies
were
candidly
and proudly
speaking those
exact words
to america
chairman
thank you for the opportunity to appear
here today for these proceedings
thank you again uh
judge ludic
as a part of the select committee's
charge to make recommendations
that are informed by other investigative
findings
we will be reviewing the views shared by
judge looted and other experts on
potential improvements to electoral
account act
among a range of other initiatives
i know the information we presented over
the last week
is shocking
the idea that a president of the united
states
would orchestrate a kink a scheme
to stay in power after the people have
voted him out of office
we're able to present this information
because so many witnesses have
cooperated with our probe
but the fact is there are more people
with direct knowledge with evidence
germane to our investigation
i ask those who might be on the fence
about cooperating to reach out to us
the committee's website address is being
displayed behind me
january 6 dot house dot gov
there you can view the evidence we
presented in our hearings and find a tip
line
to submit any information you might
think would be helpful for our
investigation
and
despite how you might not think it's
important
send us what you think and i thank those
who sent us evidence for their bravery
and patriotism
without objections members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record
including opening remarks and additional
questions for the witnesses
the chair requests those in the hearing
room remain seated until the capitol
police have escorted members from the
room
without objection the committee stands
are joined
and there you have it
the committee has adjourned for day
three
of the public hearings
of the january 6 select committee to get
to the bottom
of not just what happened on the day of
january 6 but as we've seen today
the lead up to january 6 and the
pressure campaign
that was put on
the vice president united states mike
pence
and his staff
to do the thing that john eastman
thought he had the power to do
kind of
maybe he thought he had the power to do
we see the
committee go out i'm going to bring in
my
my cohesit gabe sanchez and a midas
mighty
favorite texas ball
um fella
it um quite quite
quite an ending there with um
athletic um wow the statements that he
was making there
um where he says hey
this president tried to take away
democracy and anyone who is him or like
him
that runs for president and
possibly becomes the nominee
and the elected president in 2024 our
democracy is done so
um i'm gonna stay i'm going to stay a
little bit with the um
coverage here yesterday are they excuse
me the last time we had we had
some people come out and speak so if if
we get some people speaking we'll go to
them
but texas paul what did you think of the
uh
what did you think of that
ending statement from the judge there
where he laid out what would happen
if we let trump or anyone like trump uh
take power in the united states
uh paul get your your mic your mic needs
to be unmuted sorry
sorry about that no there you go there
you go
you know and i want to i want to tell
you if someone comes to the mic i might
cut you off so just but go ahead and
give us your thoughts on that final
statement
i was completely appreciative of his
sincerity and candidness
it's something that i've been saying for
the longest that if we do not vote
democrat in the midterm and cut the
power away from these people because
it's not just
the people that we're talking about here
the entire republican party minus two
have been complicit in this
i i mean i i've been keeping score and
so far what we've learned is trump was
told by everyone that he lost
everyone with complete credibility that
he lost he went into steel mode
everyone then told him that was credible
that you can't do that it's there's no
legal way to do it you cannot steal this
election period
but he believed you know we have jason
the miller we've got dumbass eastman we
got rudy the drunk we've got
the uh we've got steve the walking scab
bannon
um
you know telling them oh you can get
away with it you can get away with it
but he knows it's a crime
everyone has told him it's a crime it's
as though i went to rob a bank
put my team together
went into the bank and the guy that was
supposed to pick the ball
says no i'm not gonna do it
i'm still guilty
i still did it
you know
and and what's worse is
the legislatures that we're going to
work with them that's why we need to get
jenny thomas because the legislatures
that were going to work with him on this
they're like the money launderers that
would have taken my money
and laundered it later
they're guilty too
what i don't know because i'm not an
attorney is
what exactly is the statute these people
did you be prosecuted under but i'm you
know it's like the old question
what what is pornography well i can't
tell you but i know it when i see it
i know what i saw here i know what i've
seen here this is a damn crime
everybody has admitted it
everybody
i mean pence when when you went to pence
and said
steal this for me
that was a crime
uh am i crazy am i losing my mind i mean
really
uh we're gonna see maybe here maybe uh
greg jake nope greg no no he's like i
said he's like i said my two cents i'm
good
but i mean i would agree with texas paul
here is that like
just because you aren't successful in
the thing that you plan to do that was
illegal doesn't mean
that it wasn't illegal it still means
that you you were conspiring
to actually commit
this crime
and yes we are so lucky that they were
unsuccessful in this coup
but the thing that we have to remember
is it's still a crime you guys still
plan for you guys still even into you
know in the beginning of uh before the
election in 2020 you were already
building
that that narrative of it's all rigged
it's a hoax uh
they're out to get me and then when the
results come in and you find out that
trump loses then they double down on
that right i mean eastman
doesn't even believe they own the the
the story that he's trying to pull here
right like the fact if you can't if you
don't believe the own
uh your own bs that you're pushing right
that said something that says something
right there and then not only that but
then when you have eastman then say oh
[ __ ] okay this actually might be a
bigger problem than i thought i'm gonna
go ask for a pardon
and then doesn't get a pardon i mean
like you know
innocent people don't just ask for a
pardon
guilty people ask for a pardon guilty
people plead the fifth
right what did what did trump say about
that
well that's what i was going to say is
like
you have you have all these people
standing in line for pardons right
and not only that you have uh them
bleeding to fit or not even cooperating
with the select committee right uh
bannon uh mark meadows central
right yeah you've got all these people
you've got yeah bannon who just got
rejected i think yesterday the day
before for his attempt to throw it to uh
to get around his own contempt of court
you know like
these are people again that they're like
we're completely innocent everything
that we did is uh by by way of the
constitution
but you're trying to bypass how our
founding fathers the actual people that
believed in democracy
and wanted to put forward
and these people like oh no what we did
wasn't illegal we're completely innocent
but by the way if you're just going to
be writing those pardons at the end of
the year make sure to put my name on the
list please like that's what it is it's
like they're making it
why why wouldn't you want to make sure
that you're safe you know i'm on i'm on
base right like when you're a kid and
you're playing tag like i'm on base i
got my pardon ready do you i mean and
and that i guess begs to the question
because a lot of people brought it up is
did donald trump give himself a pocket
pardon um you know and do some of these
other people have pocket pardons but
it's clear now that it doesn't seem that
way that these people have pocket
buttons but i would like to see the list
of pardons that were being pimped to
donald trump what do you think texas
paul
i i
excellent question i would love to know
everybody who a got a pardon and b who
asked for one
but
again i would like to
draw to the fact that we are right now
talking about the above board things
that happen in the offices
okay um
who liaison with the proud boys
who liaison with the oath keeper that's
right that's right
the 1a praetorians that most americans
don't even know exist
but work with flynn consistently who
liaison between the white house and them
who built the bombs that got put at the
rnc and dnc
who told folks to ferry in
uh molotov cocktails
who told fox news
hey have some blm and antifa coverage
ready to go
right who liaison with these people i
mean we're not we haven't gotten to the
end of this this stinks to high heaven
man i mean this is this is just
one aspect of the coup that we're
getting here and it's already ugly as
hell
i mean this is just i mean i don't know
about you but i'm turning red
i'm mad as hell right now i mean i would
i i just i just sat down and i just
wrote that list i said
you know go back to day one trump knew
everybody told him nobody stuttered
everybody was clear you lost
you lost the day of the election
everybody came in and told them hey boss
we lost
you know
he knew
everybody told him you can't steal it
you can't everybody eastman talked who
said you're out of your mind this is
rubber room stuff i mean literally the
quote they used i i usually say nuttier
than squirrel turds but you know like
this this is this is this this stuff
that they were pimping around um
washington and again like i said earlier
they were grasping at straws any little
just drip of someone to give them
support because that's what happened in
georgia when he called brad raptors
burger that was the whole arizona thing
i mean they were grasping at any straw
that they could
to get someone to say that he had won
and he didn't he didn't [ __ ] win he
lost
and
on top of that
mike pence grasped at every straw to
find out if he could even do what the
hell eastman and trump were were saying
and i think it um
to the mike pence and proud boys thing
uh with the with the actual evidence
that they're using to say
that the proud boys were ready
to kill mike pence because we've seen in
the last few days that enrique dario
had some sort of a plan right and that's
that's the other thing that this hearing
showed is it showed rudy giuliani and
john eastman standing on stage and rudy
giuliani said in not so many words this
is part of the plan
like it was all planned this wasn't this
wasn't just a bunch of
goofy [ __ ] and manga hats
coming to washington gathering up in
front of a stage where where donald
trump puked up this vile anti-democratic
garbage
threaten mike pence if you don't do it
i'll turn my mob on you and we're gonna
go to the capitol we're gonna take this
government over and we're gonna commit a
coup and all all attentive purposes that
wasn't just a a flash in the pan that
was the intention the entire time that
was the whole plan the entire time and
it seems to be that they had plan a plan
b plan c plan d as many ways as possible
to make sure that they remained in power
and no one could stop them not even mike
pence
in that maybe the proud boys would have
killed mike pence and nancy pelosi i
mean the thing that i keep coming back
to is this administration was they were
basically throwing a rager and they
didn't want anyone to ruin the party
right they're just you know throwing
[ __ ] ruining it they're making a mess of
things and then you've got someone who
comes in and says oh actually hey guys
we should probably quiet down and pack
things up and
kind of close house so we don't get in
trouble but meanwhile you've got trump
and others who are kind of drunk on
power and be like no
we're going to live forever you know
it's like that moment in uh almost
famous where he's like i'm a golden god
like that is trump right there he's
standing on a roof denying the reality
that sits in front of him
which is he's done it's over he lost
over seven million people said you know
what you gotta go right
or 81 million but seven million people
in terms of a difference
and you look at this and these guys are
complete jokes like all of these people
despite the fact that in public
they were willing to fight and push
to stay in office or were just complicit
and not saying anything by in their
silence but once they go on record and
giving their deposition
they're like oh yeah trump he was a
complete idiot he did not live in this
reality
he could not see what was before him he
he was unable to allow
himself to be removed from office
and
i mean i i would imagine the next three
or so hearings we're going to find out
even more i mean next time guys we have
uh we have jamie raskin coming to a
microphone
so i'm going to i'm going to bring up
jamie raskin here well
we had um yeah i mean to the extent that
all of these lawyers were saying that
trump continued to try to persuade them
even though they had
categorically rejected this idea
sorry is that about the internet that
sounds like what we heard about
specifically trump's claims of election
fraud i'm talking about no it's the same
thing i mean um
you know when when we have witnesses
saying trump is calling
pence a wimp
trump is um saying he didn't have the
courage to do what needed to be done
he's obviously identifying this
disagreement i'm not saying that uh
donald trump was much interested in the
constitutional law but he clearly was
interested in getting pence to do his
will despite the fact that everybody was
telling trump that there was no
constitutional basis for what he was
asking for and is there a message
here to the department of justice that
something should be done on this some
actions should be taken on this what
you're saying
donald trump lied about the facts
that
biden beat him by more than seven
million votes and 306 to 232 an
electoral college and he lied about the
law in saying that the vice president
for the first time in american history
could assert unilateral
extra constitutional powers to reject
electoral college votes
um so
the whole thing was based on a tissue
applies congress do you want to hear
from jenny thomas and what would you
want to know from her um you know like
the chairman of our committee i'm
interested in
receiving all relevant evidence from
material witnesses
um
and so i would be interested
uh i would be interested to the extent
that she's a material witness
do you think that she has any kind of
criminal ability or
what do you make of what you've seen so
far because it sounds like you guys have
a bit of her correspondence maybe a lot
of her correspondence but as far as i
know the only thing
that i've seen is what has been seen
publicly which is
emails i don't know if there's any other
information so um to the extent that she
has uh relevant evidence and she's a
material witness i'm very interested to
see what she's going to do we know about
that
is it clearing your mind that mr eastman
has committed a crime based on the fact
that he was asking for presidential
pardons and some of the other evidence
you laid out today well the request of a
constitutional pardon as we've seen
before in this process
indicates some consciousness of guilt or
at least fear of guilt
but he's entitled to the presumption of
innocence like everyone else of course
as a lawyer he's also bound by the law
like everyone else just because he's a
lawyer doesn't mean he has any special
exemption from the criminal or civil law
but kind of
the pardon with his statements to jacob
that he knew the actions would violate
the electoral uh countdown because that
suggests at this point
knowing
and that he knowingly
violated statute or intended to violence
well the fact that he was
looking into a pardon for himself as a
lawyer
suggests either consciousness of guilt
or
fear that he might be guilty and beyond
that look every american citizen is
entitled to a presumption of innocence
and
uh you know we are not a criminal
prosecuting agency we are charged with
delivering a report to the american
people about this massive assault on
american constitutional democracy and
that's really our focus
do you think that do you think that
suggested conscience of guilt extends to
your republican colleagues who sought
pardons from the white house
um
i i would say without referring to any
particular case that a request for a
pardon suggests consciousness of guilt
or possible fear of prosecution would
you agree with the third question that
he needs a good criminal defense
i'm sorry criminal charges
uh you know i've said this from the
beginning there are different kinds of
accountability in our system of laws and
one kind of accountability is individual
criminal capability for potential
offenses
committed but another kind of
accountability is the accountability we
owe to future generations of americans
to figure out what went wrong
um we have to fortify our institutions
against coups insurrections and
political violence and subversion going
forward that to me is even more
important than individual criminal
accountability which is very important
but that's really up to the department
of justice during the hearing john
eastman actually made him put out a
statement about his correspondence with
jenny thomas and released an email
between him and her in december 2020.
uh can you confirm that the committee
has more than just one email between the
two of them that is news to me what you
just told me but is it but is it
multiple emails that the committee has
again i have not looked specific with
the emails like all that i've seen is
really what's in the newspaper i'm not
working on something read it and then
get back to us
i'm sorry uh
some of the eastman emails are there any
other obviously it's you know made you
guys interested in jenny thomas again
are there any other avenues that this
has opened up in the investigation that
you want to look more into
i'm sorry the eastman email yes the new
charge that you guys just got
hey i um know the answer to that yet
okay and then you'd a clip of mark short
uh we're calling a conversation with
kevin mccarthy about what he told either
trump or the white house uh during
january 6th and he quote expressed
frustration that the white house wasn't
taking this more seriously
that kind of seemed like obviously it
was mark short mike pence's guy but
other than that it seemed like kind of a
non-sequitur in the overall
subject of this hearing what was the
purpose of including that and what we'll
be hearing more on
in future hearings on what you know
kevin mccartney may have told people
about his conversations
um
stay tuned for that stay tuned
how would you describe the introspective
okay as we're watching jamie raskin here
i'm going to bring in
david
bender and um our co-host and texas paul
back our panel but to
see if we can get some insight
on what maybe he is saying here
david have you been listening to
what uh jamie raskin i don't know if
david's here with us
i don't think he's hearing um
what we got going on how would you
describe it how would you describe the
relationship between trump and eastman
they seem to face some testimony
yeah how would you describe the
relationship between trump and eastman
especially as a guy now now we've got
jamie ranson back at the mic a little
better
well look
if you take the big picture
donald trump refused to accept the
results of the 2020 presidential
election so the first thing they did was
the right thing to do which is you go to
court unfortunately for him the courts
came back more than 60 of them rejecting
every claim of electoral fraud and
corruption that had been suggested by
trump and his supporters so that gives
us a comprehensive and meticulous record
refuting any claims of electoral fraud
that are out there that should have been
the end of the story but then they went
as you will see in a future hearing to
the state legislatures to try to get
them just to nullify the popular vote
and devote electors uh to donald trump
they went to particular election
officials to try to browbeat them into
finding
votes for donald trump in other words to
commit election fraud and we saw that in
georgia where trump told
secretary of state brad raffensberger
just fined me 11 780 votes when all of
that didn't work there were a couple of
other
potential plans
that you'll hear about including the
idea of seizing the election machinery
and getting the military to re-run the
election because everybody knows about
that provision in the constitution where
the military can seize the election
machinery and rerun the election right
so that one also evaporated but then it
all came down to january the 6th it was
all about can we get mike pence to
violate his constitutional duties step
outside of his constitutional role and
then nullify electoral college votes
that have been cast by multiple states
representing tens of millions of voters
that was the whole thing so when you ask
what was
trump's relationship with eastman in the
final days there it was
uh it was that trump was relying on
eastman uh to give legal cover to an
absurd legal theory uh which was
advancing an absurd factual hypothesis
which was that donald trump had actually
won the election
that you amend the electoral contact um
i think that uh
the experience we've just been through
uh indicates that there are fixes to the
electoral account act that need to
happen speaking as one member of the
committee uh to my mind that alone would
be insufficient to the enormity of the
challenges it faces on top of that what
would be
we'll be getting into it more deeply on
top of the electoral college
we'll be getting into it more deeply
there are lots of there are lots of
problems i mean for example if all we
said was that the vice president does
not have an authority to do what no one
ever thought he had an authority to do
that would obviously be radically
insufficient to the task
and we also have to be careful not to be
fighting the last battle because
as judge ludwig stated cogently at the
end of the hearing the threat is still
very much out there for 2024 nobody
believes that vice president harris is
going to try to steal the presidential
election for donald trump or anyone else
do you have any thoughts on the senate's
negotiations with the
eca
i haven't seen the details of it on top
of that mr raskin uh we we saw a new
email showing that mr eastman had asked
for a pardon from the president do you
think that it is still possible for the
department of justice to entice or
otherwise prosecute people like mr
eastman who would otherwise saw a pardon
and do you think that this made the case
with the justice department well it's
obviously not illegal for him to seek a
pardon so that there's that's not a
criminal act in itself the question is
whether that is indicative of his
consciousness of guilt uh or his fear of
prosecution based on uh
all of the actions he had undertaken in
conjunction with donald trump uh and i
think those are all legitimate questions
and they certainly
bear more
factual inquiry can i just as uh with
regards to these pardons both with mr
eastman and the members of congress
known and unknown do you have details
about uh what they said they're
specifically seeking a pardon for we
know about scott perry your colleague uh
miss cheney mentioned him yeah do you at
least can you tell us if you have
the details about what explicitly they
said they want to be pardoned no i do
not have that um information uh and i'm
not certain what they asked for
um i will only say that uh judge carter
in california in the eastman litigation
who was the only judge to opined on this
uh said that he thought that it was
likely that donald trump had engaged in
federal criminal offenses specifically a
conspiracy to obstruct a federal
proceeding
and other potential offenses including
basically depriving
um the american people in the government
of uh a fair election do you think
there's any illegal has the committee
i i don't know the answer to that
question sorry congressman
do you think you're running against time
with the midterms and the summer recess
well i i understand there's been some
interest in the senate which as you know
is always the the minefield
in some reforms the electoral count act
and um i know we have been also talking
about reforms to electoral account act
so i would say
minute that at a minimum that's what we
should be able to
uh expect before the next presidential
election but again um if that's all
we're looking at i think we've set our
sights way too low
i don't know the answer to that
congressman um
earlier this year the former president
said that if any prosecutor tried to get
him there should be massive protests
washington atlanta and new york et
cetera et cetera
who said that the former president
donald trump said that at one of his
rallies um
do these hearings and the information
that's coming out because of them does
that help give prosecutors in atlanta uh
and perhaps in d.c
more legitimacy among you know the
electorate among populists that yeah
what he did was wrong and beyond because
by i haven't thought of that question i
mean obviously
the department of justice federal
prosecutors state and local prosecutors
have
an obligation to
fairly
enforce the law and to base their
prosecutions on the law and the facts
uh without regard to public opinion so i
hope that the no prosecutors waiting
around to take a poll on whether this or
that person should be prosecuted because
that is not the proper function of law
enforcement
um
our
role in this process uh under house
resolution 503 is to determine what
happened on january sex what were the
causes behind it and what do we need to
do going forward in order to
secure the progress of american
democracy the institutions and values
that we all depend on so that's really
what our focus has been um
and uh
you know uh
i
i take judge ludwig's warning at the end
quite seriously i mean you know this is
a conservative judicial hero i mean he's
like at the level of justice scalia and
robert bork for
right-wing conservatives in america i
mean that's not my
legal crowd
but he came out and he said that the
rule of law is at stake democracy is in
danger and he's not just talking about
what happened in 2020 he was very clear
at the end he's talking about what might
happen in 2024 so
we have to stay focused on the danger
still being out there and um
you know
judge uh judge ludwig may have gotten a
uh somewhat into the weeds in the the
beginning of the hearing in his
discussion uh but i was glad that he
said what he did at the end because it
explains why someone who is such a died
in the wool conservative republican
is making this rather dramatic gesture
of coming out to say we're in danger
from trump and trumpism going into the
2024 elections that's coming from a guy
who sat as one of the most conservative
judges in the land on the fourth circuit
court of appeals that's an incredibly
powerful and important warning
that we ignore at our own peril
i think i better head back to my office
so there you have jamie raskin as we
watch him uh
go away there we have our panel of
guests with us thanks for sticking
around for us um
we um
we kind of flashed to uh jamie raskin
there just because um
i wanted to hear what he had to say and
he brought up a lot of good points these
reporters asked him a lot of things
about
about
the pardons that everyone was i've been
talking about today um jessica thank you
for joining us david thank you for
joining us uh jessica what do you think
about the the pardons and the inside the
circle wanting the pardons
and you know you had spoke about the
the inner circle of trump and how all
these people kind of react and this sort
of thing so give us give us your take on
the pardons if you would
it's kind of a fitting end to a criminal
presidency isn't it all of the inquirers
asking the pres the criminal president
for pardons and we don't know if he gave
himself a pocket pardon right that's a
big big outstanding question right right
but the beauty of
that is that
fanny willis is very much on a track for
prosecution in fulton county in georgia
and a federal pardon doesn't get you out
of a state indictment that's right
that's right so we can all
congratulate and thank funny willis for
her tenacity and in pursuing trump
um but what one of the things that i
just heard asked of raskin was the
question that i think
is really the elephant in the room and
that was
are you concerned or something about the
comment that trump made at a rally about
threatening
mobs in the street
and if you don't think that this is
something that is that prosecutors are
concerned about and have been and a lot
probably uh this is a looming threat
that has prevented a lot of action
against him again but i really think
we're at a moment to confront this and
we have to confront it if we don't
confront the threat of trump mob
violence to preventing him from being
held accountable then we're just living
in a banana republic i mean we might as
well just call ourselves for now because
that is not like judge ludwig so
beautifully articulated
the rule of law so um this is our
opportunity and speaking of mobs in the
streets how about we right now
resolve to demand peacefully and if it
takes coming into washington making our
uh you know showing up making our voices
heard that we are going to demand and
support the department
moving forward with what it means to do
peacefully supporting the rule of law
or yeah david
i i think you i think you're right that
it is a when you said it's a a
a fitting end to a criminal presidency
that everyone is lining up to get
pardons for these crimes but i also
think you're right about the violence
because
he also said the idea that that that the
vice president now
would do what they were asking the vice
president to do then is no one's even
no one's even thinking of that right
like no one even has that on on the map
even
because i mean i would imagine just like
every vice president before her they
would not do that to our democracy
um david what says you about this
pardon line and um the emails too
uh because
we've seen a lot of emails back and
forth today as well um which i think the
back and forth between
uh one of the witnesses greg jacob the
council to the vice president mike pence
and eastman
is one of the most telling of what they
were really trying to do right like i
mean jacob said in so many words
what the hell did you just try to do and
he's like what what do you mean we tried
to overthrow the government i mean
that's basically not in so many words
but
it seems to be that's the way people
would take that email i i think he
actually said were this is all because
of your [ __ ] yes right
and and that's not so many words it's
just one and
already used
but
look it what what's trending now i'm
told on twitter uh
first is the top of twitter is january
6th
second is john eastman as people try and
figure out
who who this man is who tried to help
overthrow
our republic
uh one of the uh one of the tweets that
i liked
quite a lot was what's the irony of
someone uh taking the fifth amendment to
the constitution for protection
a document he just tried to overthrow
right it it it seems there you know
we're we're post irony here so i don't
expect
john eastman to to note that or anyone
else
but i think we did there's a huge amount
of news that was made
we didn't know we didn't have a document
that was public until today of eastman
saying
you know if this pardon thing is still
going on i think i might want to be
considered
uh and and to jennifer jessica's points
excuse me jessica is right the pocket
pardon for those who don't understand it
is
where donald trump could have
written himself a little note
that can be opened at whatever point
uh
he decides i guess
uh i'm not sure and jessica you may know
where did those live
where where do those
notes itself your pardon where do they
live
i'm sure they're in a box at mar-a-lago
but other than that along with the other
documents no doubt of course of course
but but so let me let me ask you
you had a further question could one
such note exist for eastman
you're the expert there i don't know
i'm not aware yeah well that's why i'm
betting on friday
that's why i'm betting on fraud because
even if he did give himself a pardon you
can pardon yourself today
but if you do it again tomorrow the
pardon does not apply
and when i
started defrauding
his base
for a legal defense that did not exist
he can pardon himself all day long all
the way up to january 20th but if he
took one dollar after january 20th that
pardon isn't worth the paper it's
written on
right it's not work paper it's written
so criminal acts ongoing are are
unprotected and as chess points out uh
in georgia as we know in new york state
uh
all of this is uh
something that is subject to uh
state law but not it can't be dealt with
federally so department wouldn't apply
to anything that happened in with
rothenberger the pardon wouldn't apply
to anything that happened with the trump
organization
i've got a clip here of the uh of
the eastman part where it talks about
pardons and where he starts to uh plead
the fifth let's let's watch a bit of
this
tony you know we're not hearing the
sound on it yeah we can't hear the sound
there are we back now let's see what
daughter yeah
two days later
eastman emailed rudy giuliani and
requested that he be included on a list
of potential recipients of a
presidential pardon
dr eastman's email stated quote
i've decided that i should be on the
pardon list
yes
dr eastman did not receive his
presidential pardon
so let's see what dr eastman did so so
that's when he was deposed so this guy i
mean everyone kind of giggled there i
mean you know here's a guy here's a guy
who's who's
who's obviously has some uh criminal
liability here because he's like well if
i can get one i might as well get one
now i like it again and get the end why
the getting is good you know well it's
not it's also not uh i mean it's totally
on brand right you look at other people
like bannon or navarro who who have gone
and said i have executive privilege just
because i was standing next to trump i
deserve it like these are all people
from that administration who believe
just by association
that they are privileged enough to
receive those things despite the fact
that they were doing illegal things in
the present during the administration
but they think they're like well i know
that guy like you know it's like trying
to get into a club and saying that you
know the bounce or you know someone else
right that's what's happening here
saying that like i think i should be on
the list you should put me on the list
right i think i should have this
executive privilege i should be covered
i should have a pardon it's just you
know it's i mean it's complete bs
obviously but it is that whole like i'm
totally deserving of these things
because i said so
well while we're on the subject
and i have the platform um president
biden
i beat the brakes off a guy once so if
that pardon thing's still going on
i would like one if you don't mind right
i'm an avid supporter and you know
i i didn't mean it
well i
will sign the letter for you
i mean we're all we're all you know and
that that's the funny part we hear that
jared was in there working on pardons
now
in in fairness and in truth from what i
understand
there really was
uh an effort to get trump to look at
real pardons because there have been a
whole and
i hate saying in fairness to jared and
ivanka but they had been working with
criminal justice groups to get
non-violent offenders pardoned and that
is true and they had and they had they
had
some success with it i mean they did
again not giving them too much credit
but they didn't have some success with
that but but you you give the doubles
they're due and then you point out that
so many of the other pardons were things
that did not go through channels didn't
go through you know all the letters that
we're going to write on texas paul's
behalf they went
they went right into a phone call to
trump going literally
as he was in mar-a-lago his lab pardon
was to
janine perro's judge janine's husband
ex-husband
that he was landing it was minutes
before he was done uh and and frankly
he'd be giving them out now if he could
say right right say that the clock
stopped at you know one minute to noon
on on the 20th
um what was interesting was that whole
rationale you see eastman saying well
since obviously the electoral account
act doesn't apply uh you know we can we
can continue doing this what he meant
was it didn't apply because
a riot
delayed the certification of the boats
and and therefore
it's
we don't need to worry about it anymore
i mean
there's a word for that um hutzpah is
great
well you know i remember in that in that
moment
um
after january 6
when the president at the time donald
trump went silent right we weren't
hearing anything from him we didn't we
didn't know
if he was ankle deep in a in a bucket of
chicken or what was going on right like
we could not tell but we did see a scene
one of those days and i'm not sure the
exact
um date i believe it's the 18th or the
19th but you see rudy giuliani you see
jared and ivanka and you see other
characters that have to do with these
quote unquote pardons show up at the
white house
all in one day all in one sort of
meeting and jessica has been in some of
these meetings before with these folks
um because she she's been on the trump
team as everyone knows she's the trump
nba killer um but so she
has seen the inside workings of how
these people you know have meetings and
stuff do you think there's something to
all these folks meeting at the white
house on that day just before january
20th where jared's saying i'm working on
pardons i'm working on pardons and rudy
giuliani's showing up and other people
are showing up in the white house do you
think that had anything to do with the
pardon line that we are seeing forming
here
it had everything to do with it of
course of course
i mean can we just step back for a
minute and think about who jared and
ivanka are yeah i'll never forget
walking into trump tower one day and
nobody could stand ivanka trump and
trump tower by the way she would walk
and be like hi everybody and everybody
would just be silent
but
i'll never forget one day walking in and
she was about to give one of her
probably more publicized speeches um on
behalf of trump on the campaign and she
was in this conference room all by
herself with a platform and a podium and
a teleprompter and she was just standing
there in the room by herself like
i mean this is a fragrance um brander
that was brought into the white house as
a senior advisor
her husband is the son of a convicted
criminal um who could not
you know it was was unsuccessful also in
real estate as was his father-in-law and
um these are the people that were
brought in
before they were issuing pardons to a
long list of criminals and mostly
as we're talking about are a lot of them
being trump cronies trump friends
before that um
they were working with the highest
security clearance
in the administration a security
clearance that they did not earn that
that was told that trump was told was
recommended against and he overrode
these security clearances so just take a
step back for a minute and think about
who these people are that are made
thinking of our country it is just so
unfathomable so
yeah i think that that meeting was
definitely about that and how
unqualified they were until the friggin
11th hour of that corrupt criminal
presidency to issue pardons for the
people that they were speaking of bannon
and if you followed my case at all he's
very integral in my original
foundational lawsuit against the trump
campaign which is still ongoing and he
has been served in my case to testify
and you know what he did when he was
served with those papers he threw them
on the sidewalk outside of his townhouse
at capitol hill and i have a video on it
i'll retweet it on my twitter feed
bring that up bring that up there is
currently
in addition to his criminal uh contempt
motion there is a pending motion from my
team in dc superior court to hold him in
contempt
and compel compliance with that civil
subpoena so
well well i just want a question to ask
yeah
about steve bannon and i apologize it is
a childish question
but does he smell as bad as he looks
because you know that i mean and you've
been in the room with him i mean you can
tell us that he does he's
there's a reason they brought in a
fragrance brander though no that could
be yeah let's see what's also i mean
let's give ivanka some credit she's not
just a fragrance brander she also owns a
shoe line but then again she did get
sued for stealing the designs for the
shoes so
it is what it is but actually one thing
that you pissed off about that
the one thing that you brought up
jessica was that just her her
uh the facade right i come in and i'm
such a great presenter
i mean the thing that immediately came
back to my mind was when she went at the
g20 summit and tried to inject herself
into a group of people and talk and then
he was like
like nobody wanted to acknowledge
because she has no merit and she has no
qualifications
but of clearly is able to make millions
under the administration because her
death millions of millions from china
right exactly so we're
yeah absolutely
so um
back to
off of the uh steve bannon stench there
holy moly i would appreciate if you uh
retweet that video i'd i'd love to i'd
love to see that well i logged into
twitter because it was taking up too
much energy but when i only yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure
tweet that put it up at the top and
everyone can see it speaking of that go
go follow go follow everyone here on the
screen on on on twitter i don't think
david do you have a twitter not on your
life okay okay well every
one so this is very this is a very
special moment right here right follow
everyone but david we wouldn't we
wouldn't uh
i am i'm an amish luddite okay
that's good
me gabe texas paul and jessica make sure
to go follow him on twitter because
you're not going to want to miss that
video about steve bannon but also i want
to mention that uh here on the midas
media network we are gonna carry all
these hearings it looks like
next week um and david can confirm this
if i'm wrong but uh there's gonna be a
tuesday and a thursday hearing at the
same exact time right right so they're
going to start at 1 00 p.m eastern when
they gavel down but we're going to start
our covers just like we did today an
hour before to do the commentary we'll
have a panel like we have here maybe
some of these great folks here will be
joining us next tuesday and next
thursday and and we will be giving
commentary but we will produce this uh
the show for you with our licensed
cameras right there in washington
uh to see all the footage from the
january 6th select hearing so make sure
make sure please to go follow the midas
touch youtube page and also also i'll be
jordy
yeah what's that yeah
yeah yeah there you go yeah yeah yeah go
comment and like and subscribe too
also go to our channel the tony michaels
podcast uh gabe's done such a great job
uh helping produce uh these hearings so
go follow over there as well and you can
download these episodes i believe the my
zealous brothers are gonna put them up
on all the uh these hearings on the
directory so go download these as well
on apple spotify google your your
favorite place also i got a special
promo code for all the minus money you
can use the word justice at
store.minustouch.com
for 10 off all your merch that's justice
at
store.midastouch.com i speaking of the
word justice you know what reminds me
that ball bat behind that attorney who
was telling john eastman
uh you better you better go get a
[ __ ] attorney because you're gonna
need
oh well
so that it you know clear although
apparently that didn't matter again we
saw lots of bombs dropped by uh
with little warning from uh pete aguilar
you know uh one of the things that it
kept coming back to me we talked about
the fifth amendment uh at the top of
this uh i just sent you something tony i
don't know if if you see it in your
inbox but i i just texted you uh a clip
that i i haven't seen in a long time but
we just pulled it here uh it's uh
something that uh
uh the former guy
used to say all the time
about the fifth amendment uh
do you have it
uh let me see if i can pull it up here
as i guess we're uh as we're going on a
fly here but yeah i think i know what he
said he said oh no no i was hoping we
would hear him say it is the point not
not spoiling but but let me if you can
pull it up uh great and if not uh
gabe can you see if you can find that
clip i'm not having it it's moving that
link it's an old c-span and we i think
we all know what he said we're waiting
for you to pull that up i wanted to draw
your attention to one thing did anybody
else catch the overt threat that donald
trump made to mike pence when he was at
the rally
they were on stage in the circle he said
word for word
it takes courage to do nothing
that was a direct threat
that was
if you do not do what i want you to do
believe me
this is going to be far worse for you
right than if you then any discomfort
you think you're going to have
doing what you're objecting to doing
it's almost like he knew that the proud
boys were willing to i don't know kill
him i i don't know maybe it seems like
the biggest threat we heard revealed
today
was i won't be your friend anymore
i mean really in what universe does that
i i thought that was seventh grade
um
and apparently it still is
well uh i think jessica has to hop here
jessica i want to thank you again for
joining us make sure make sure to
retweet that so we can spread that that
video around i really appreciate you
joining us uh in the the early coverage
and after please if you can next week
join us again we'd love to hear your
your bannon stories or and you know how
the stench is around him maybe we'll get
to the bottom of that uh thank you very
much jessica for joining us everybody
the trump nba killer thank you jessica
on twitter thank you very much have a
good one
uh
i just i just sent you the link for uh
what i think is an aggregate of five
times that trump has mentioned
people taking the fifth amendment and
who those types of people are so oh so
this is this is a uh
this is a uh uh you're saying
this is he's not just said it once he
said yeah he said it multiple times okay
well uh let me see if i can pull this up
here
uh
hang on we're producing on the fly here
and we can send it to the committee
because they ought to be playing this
right as they reference it sure sure
well i'm sure i'm sure they'll actually
um get around to playing a lot of trump
clips they have already have this is one
that's particularly telling because he
this is what you want to direct people's
attention to all right here is the um
let's see if we can pull it up here here
is a clip
that
apparently we hear five times
oh
take here we go
when you have
your staff
taking the fifth amendment taking the
fifth
so they're not prosecuted when you have
the man that set up the illegal server
taking the fifth
i think it's disgraceful fifth amendment
bob the mob
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment fifth amendment good
question horrible horrible he pleaded
the fifth and that was the end we never
heard about him again this is like
watergate
only it's worse
because here
our foreign enemies were in a position
to hack
our most sensitive national security
secrets
so so there is there is uh the
the
i mean straight from the horse's mouth
he said
yeah it's the other end of the horse
come on
it is a horse's ass well you know i i
actually want to point something out
speaking of the stench of steve bannon
we haven't seen a lot of the stench of
steve bannon and the reason why we
haven't is because he refused to
actually cooperate with the select
committee right um i think that's very
significant and that people need to
understand is we're not seeing clips of
some of these folks like um
john eastman uh well he's pleading the
fifth we've seen a lot of that but
that's almost that's that's probably
john the fifth is that
there it is
but but we're not going to see or smell
the coverage or the clips of steve
bannon
um
testifying and giving his testimony to
the january 6th select committee because
he refused and actually yesterday i
believe a judge decided in that case
that no you are still held in contempt
we're not going to where you know he's
he's going to lose these cases oh yeah
um to try to throw out these charges
because it's obvious
especially now like now as the evidence
is piling up and it's starting to come
out we're starting to see this evidence
it's going to get more and more it's
definitely a really bad time for him to
be going through a trial right now or
try to reject it when they're like oh
man so a new new source of evidence came
in all right great you know like it
doesn't it doesn't play well for him i
don't know how like i don't know what
his end game is here obviously is to try
to get those rejected obviously it
didn't
it didn't work out um but like i said
tony it's it's one of those things where
as the hearings go on
you know i'd be very curious you know i
did a segment that we just had on what
was that about navarro i'd be very
curious to see what new details come out
of navarro because his his appearance
actually has to be tomorrow based on his
two charges of contempt of congress so
i'm curious what what if anything comes
out of there and what might actually be
added to the hearings if they go into
the green bay sweep and talk more about
navarro and eastman so well there is
some there is some news on um
some of these criminal charges because
we're talking about the contempt of uh
of congress charges um but with other
charges it seems like the proud boys
hearing are excuse me the trial for the
oath keepers and the proud boys it seems
to be that it's they're going to push it
past the election into december and i
believe um a lot of this is you know
stalling the federal courts are good at
that i mean they do that a lot but
here's the thing is that
um with the evidence that we had today
and the proud boys the proud boys uh
trial being pushed past the election
don't you think david that that is
possible
of saying you know this this these
trials these dojs these charges if they
bring charges against navarro against
bannon against eastman here
for some of their rudy giuliani or trump
himself
um it's gonna push past the the election
the midterm
it doesn't that just
a lot of people are gonna be upset about
that but doesn't that just go to that
the doj really isn't doing this based on
the election like they're doing it based
on the crimes that were committed and
the work they have to do to convict
these people of those crimes and it
shows that with that with that new news
that the proud boys trial is going to be
pushed i mean it just shows that this
isn't contrived this isn't political on
the doj criminal side
well
here's the frustration we are we're we
have an insurrection
it started uh before january 6 it's
going on now
it has not stopped it's taken a
different form they're not people trying
to storm buildings there are people
trying to change laws and succeeding at
it to make insurrection
essentially legal in the sense that you
can invalidate
the state results this is designed to
have the states we're going to see it
when the court rules next week or two
weeks on it may be next week on roe v
wade this is all about giving states the
right to decide these things
but if they throw out
which by the way clarence thomas you
remember him that's jenny's husband
but clarence thomas is in favor of
abolishing the electoral count act
i
he is not alone uh in bush v gore uh he
in the
concurring opinion that that gave bush
the election
uh rehnquist
uh scalia
uh the great lake scalia who was the
hero to uh our judge today ludwig
modeled himself after scalia
both of them and clarence thomas who
ostensibly is still alive
quiet but alive
he
has said
it should be tossed what happens if the
electoral count act is tossed then all
these things where we've seen arizona
we've seen wisconsin all these uh
you know
efforts to
do audits post-election audits
won't matter
the state legislature will be empowered
to decide on their own
who is president
who the electors are you can win 75 of
the vote in georgia you don't need
raffensburg anymore you have the
legislature and they can decide that's
where this is headed
and the problem we got
as i see it is the courts are not
designed for this
we it took two and a half years for don
mcgann
to be told that he had to cooperate with
the mueller investigation which was long
closed
so what do we got we've got a situation
where they know it's stall ball they'll
play this out beat the clock in any
civil court that there is because that's
the nature of our system it moves
somebody told me this many many years
ago i you know it the wheels of justice
turn but they turn slowly
okay so if they turn slowly and it takes
till
2025 to get some of these people on
trial hey
uh who gets a pardon on uh you know the
21st of january
in 2025 actually at 1201 on january 20th
20
a whole bunch of people they might have
a stack they might have a whole stack of
papers ready to go ready to go and
that's that's that's my point the
criminal justice system and and the
civil justice system not set up for an
insurrection
lincoln knew that
lincoln
that's why lincoln uh suspended abus
corpus right and used military tribunals
and put insurrectionists in jail
there was a reason
right now
i'm not saying that joe biden should do
that but i'm saying that we are
hamstrung by the fact that we play by
the rules and they don't right well
texas paul because i know you speak
about this a lot what can we do about
this because we've got just a few more
minutes here uh before we wrap what can
we do this year because i know i know
we're i know we're coming in on on this
midterm so what can we do this year
because you you always speak so great
about this
all right
uh
just speaking to the american people in
general okay
this is the most important election of
your lifetimes right now right now and
you have to
hurt yourself in this election you have
to look me in the eye you have to donate
like you've never donated before find
good candidates volunteer phone bank
get your butt out there in the heat and
knock on some doors you don't have to
live if you've got like if you like bedo
here in texas
you can be in michigan and phone bank
form i mean get out there and do what
you've got to do to get this done
because if we lose this election if the
republicans have a wave and they end up
taking congress
they will believe me they will abolish
the filibuster immediately they will i
mean if they get 51 in congress that's
in in the senate that's it filibusters
out and you're going to see the most
radical agenda you've ever seen you're
talking about
taxes they're talking about raising
taxes on everybody that makes under a
hundred thousand dollars uh 1500 bucks a
year they're talking about sun setting
medicare medicaid and social security
that means that every five years we've
got a vote to re-up it or it goes away
can you imagine the kind of
blackmail they will put on democrats
every five years i mean we end up in
that position all the time we're trying
to save something for the american
people and the republicans make us give
a big fat juicy steak
to their donors
or they will screw the american people
that's what they want to do with
medicare and social security
not to mention you know they've talked
about wanting to get rid of uh you know
um
oh god i'm tired now
right um
every i mean all kinds of
why i mean the longer the short the
longer the short i think you're getting
that here is that if we don't go vote if
we don't try our best and make this the
most important election of our lifetimes
that there's there's dire consequences
and the next one and the next one
because they are not gonna stop they're
not gonna stop um trying to break down
our democracy because they know that's
the only way they're they're really dumb
ideas i guess you would say win uh david
i know i know you have to bounce here
and i know we only have a few minutes so
if you would give us give us your last
word
my last word is
amen
because the to to what texas paul said
you got to vote you've got to help even
if you're not in that state where
there's a contested election
but amen is the word of the day because
what you're gonna see on the sound bites
tonight my friends
is the bible
the bible was invoked
they were praying before they came in
they were praying in the capital uh the
country
is going to respond to that
and and this was not an accident that
that line of questioning went there
there's a lot of prayer that we all
ought to be engaged in
no matter
as someone said we probably pray to the
same god it doesn't matter we better
pray
because if this does not work and texas
paul is right if we see a republican
house and senate uh come november
um
it will be a sad sad day
uh for all of us and that's why we can't
let it happen
that's right that's right well i
appreciate it david at christmas welcome
connecticut was a griswold v connecticut
yes
they said that is their next target
marcia blackburn has said it publicly
several times griswold is next they want
women at home pregnant
not working
that
it's insane what these folks have i mean
you've got
you've got them out there preaching for
a christian theocracy i mean excuse me
you know who the hell runs that greg
locke are you kidding me what about all
my jewish friends what about my muslim
friends what about my forget that man
you're out of your damn mind you're
already here you know what the other
thing i will give you a good laugh the
other sound bite will be to your point
out out of the damn mind we're going to
have everyone googling the term rubber
room right yeah
that's that's what it came down to we
were all in a national rubber room yeah
walls i think we still are a little bit
yeah i mean we are currently you know as
you said you know there's a is a it's a
complete regression
of society right now as they're pulling
away rights and taking and going back
and saying you actually don't have that
and you don't have that that is what's
happening they are slowly picking the
tree clean of the leaves
and regressing the uh
the the
uh the rights that we have as citizens
in this country
well let's get to work
thank you david thank you texas
before you go david i want to leave you
with a funny thought in your mind
okay i come from a god family i'll tell
you i've i've i'm you know i've
if you want to to bring a case you have
to actually sit down as an agent and go
sit down with an ausa
and pitch your case
can you imagine the agent that draws the
lucky straw that says i've got this bad
hombre right here that threatened mike
pence's life and we need to lock this
guy up and the ausa says oh really let
me take a look at the file
spies
[Laughter]
spazz
we're gonna
thank you for closing texas paul style
uh with spaz thanks david thanks tessa's
paul you guys go back and join us next
week okay um and so uh gabe i tell you
what i tell you what um
what
a lot of fun um we had a couple
technical difficulties there but we
worked through yeah i'm blaming i'm
blaming not us i'm blaming
no no i i actually i actually think i
don't know i think it was my browser
window or something was was floating so
i had to turn off turn back on and get
get back so it worked out and i
appreciate everyone sticking around for
us again
follow midas touch for next week because
we're going to cover every single one of
these hearings live we'll have the
commentary before the commentary during
the break and the commentary after so
you don't want to miss anything so
subscribe down below on to the midas
touch youtube channel also subscribe to
our channel as well the tony michaels
podcast me and gabe do a show every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch we also simulcast
from the minus touch facebook page so
you'll catch us over there and you can
download us
on apple spotify google
and also don't forget don't forget you
got a a great special promo code uh for
today's broadcast at the store dot minus
touch.com go get all your merch over
there 10 percent off just use the promo
code and justice
justice just like the bat just like the
bat on the wall just
right well we never could determine what
the hell that i don't know i i think
those i think the metal the metal uh the
chrome like thing whatever on the wall
whatever i think they're chrome styled
hair pieces
looks like it's long hair like like a
hair helmet like a hair it looks like
they're metal hair helmets so like when
you have to bash someone over the head
you just put that on as protection
it's like a baseball bat war type thing
yeah it's a weird republican kind of
activity you know i i get you go follow
us also at tonymichaelspot on twitter
and at the tonymichaels and follow gabe
at i am gabe sanchez again
gabe every single one of these hearings
there's going to be an hour before so
next week here's what's going to happen
folks on the minus touch youtube channel
at noon eastern an hour before the
gamble falls we will start our coverage
we'll have special guest special
commentary with a panel of the midas
media network do not miss it go set your
reminders now we know
we know that we have one postpone one
was postponed yesterday
you know potentially we have another one
that will be added you know they still
have to fill in for a day that you know
i was thinking about that this morning
about the timing of these and how
they're doing them because we are we're
trying to get the timing ourselves
because really sometimes like we don't
even know
like no one's giving us an official
schedule like we don't get it ahead of
time i mean like when they released the
original schedule they said this is yeah
right as is but can change right and we
saw you know they postpone a day then
they changed all of the hearings that
were in the morning to start in the
afternoon on the east coast right and i
think that's i think that's because some
of this evidence
like like the like the louder milk uh
video that we got yesterday it kind of
filled in the space for that hearing but
i think you know we kind of went back
and forth the other day on our show
about this idea that maybe maybe they're
just trying to let this marinate in the
news to let americans grab all yeah i
mean i think
because it's a lot of information it is
it's a lot to digest you know we talked
about it which is like actually going
through
and
uh and not rushing it right and they're
giving them bite-sized you know sound
bites and things that people can share
trend hashtag whatever to keep the
momentum right instead of throwing one
big boulder into a pool of water they're
throwing these little pebbles to kind of
keep the ripples going now they might
have bigger rocks that they throw in but
they're consistently dropping in these
little sound bites and clips and and
right uh or you know images or or what
have you and so i think they're doing a
really good job of that and so we'll
find out exactly what happens
with an additional one or maybe they i
mean there was talks originally of
having eight of them they scaled down to
six maybe they go back to eight maybe
they do go back to you know i i don't
know exactly what's going to happen here
but i do know something is that they're
telling us a story right and the the
select committee is strategically
telling us a story of what happened and
why we should pay attention to these
little elements because even beyond
these hearings there's no way to stuff
in everything that happened leading up
to the events of january 6 the day
before that day the day after there's no
way to stuff all that into just a few
hours a couple times a week over a month
there's just no way to do that yeah but
they're doing the best they can to tell
the story and i think that's what you
need to be doing out there audience is
you need to be helping tell the story so
when you see these clips don't just
share them around if you're in front of
someone get your phone out go to twitter
show them i i see this
i was talking to someone yesterday gabe
um and this person had not heard of the
250 million dollars that trump had stole
defrauded his supporters from from an
election uh defense fund that did not
exist they're like what
they're like wait a second 250 million
bucks i'm like 250
million with an m right dollars the big
with a big m with a big m
a quarter of a billion dollars they took
under the guys that it was going to be
used for lawyers for the election right
and there was no such thing as this
election spoiler alert just he lied to
you right you lied to everyone which you
know very on brand for trump he says
i'll take the money i'll use it for this
and then he turns his back and he goes
psych and then uses it for his own
personal gain right to pay off his own
personal debts absolutely because that's
really what it was he's paying off his
own debts because he's broke but that's
the thing is this this person had never
heard of that before and they and even
even the news had broke we had seen this
in the hearing and they still hadn't
heard it so it is up to you folks it's
up to you audience to go out there and
talk to the people in your community
talk to the people at your church at the
school at the playground that that when
you're checking out with groceries it is
up to you
that you know this information and you
arm americans with this information not
just people who vote for democracy but
people who may have been duped by trump
and his allies it is so important there
was there was actually development it
looks like the doj has requested
transcripts for all of the january 6
committee depositions which is amazing
to hear we know there were talks of you
know people like oh mayor garland isn't
doing enough right and you know he's
playing you know he's bit playing chess
here he's slowly moving the pieces
across the board to line it up because
one this committee has already done such
an incredible job of deposing so many
people getting so many depositions and
having it on the record and not only
that but they've already done the job of
categorizing
clips and images and emails and texts
they've done the hard work and now the
doj is like great you've already give it
over you've already done all this which
means that we can potentially go forward
and prosecute maybe quicker than we
would before right you see like we said
the oath keepers and the proud boys it's
moving to december again like i feel
like everyone is beginning to work
together to say january 6 we couldn't
have done it without you because you
guys put in all the hard work and now
that we have all this stuff we can
actually make a case i think so i think
so and thank you for joining us audience
make sure to look out for those dates
next week uh right now tentatively they
are tuesday and thursday uh the the the
gavel goes down at one pm eastern but
join us here on the midas media network
at noon eastern
nine pacific right here on the midas
media network make sure to subscribe and
watch for those links so you do not miss
those hearings until next week thank you
very much thank you for joining us we'll
see you soon gabe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you